donc comme vous le savez le président
bourlange aurait vraiment aimé être ici
aujourd'hui il s'en excuse il a eu un
impératif mais nous recevons donc
aujourd'hui la ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères afin qu'elles
puissent nous éclairer sur certains
développements de l'actualité
internationale qui nous préoccupe tout
particulièrement et dont nous avons
parlé lors du dernier bureau madame la
ministre je vous remercie d'avoir bien
voulu aménager un agenda
particulièrement chargé pour venir
prendre ce temps d'échange avec nous
vous n'étiez pas plus tard qu'hier en
Arménie et avant-hier encore en Ukraine
alors nous sommes privilégiés de vous
avoir nous devions aujourd'hui discuter
nous entretenir sur la situation au
Niger et au Gabon et plus généralement
l'Afrique occidentale et sahénienne mais
les événements du 20 septembre au Karaba
et leur répercussions ont bouleversé
quelques peu l'agenda de notre
commission et l'objet de cette réunion
beaucoup de membres de notre commission
ont en effet souhaité profiter de votre
retour d'Erevan pour faire le point à ce
sujet et donc nous vous remercions par
avance de l'éclairage que vous pourrez
nous donner
le déroulement d'un véritable nettoyage
ethnique je pense qu'on peut employer
cette expression au aucun Rabat et les
menaces à peine voilées préférée à
l'encontre de l'intégrité territoriale
en Arménie nous choque profondément
comme beaucoup de nos concitoyens la
France qui est une amie fidèle de
l'Arménie et démenée depuis plusieurs
mois pour tenter de trouver une solution
à la crise humanitaire provoquée par le
blocage du corridor de la Chine et aussi
à la question diplomatique qui se pose
plus généralement avec l'Azerbaïdjan
vous vous êtes rendu sur place et nous
savons que notre diplomatie est à
l'oeuvre à New York à Bruxelles et
ailleurs pour garantir l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Arménie et protéger
ses populations qui aspirent à vivre en
paix
nous allons aussi quand même prendre le
temps de parler du volet africain qui
était quand même l'objet de cette
audition et de la succession de coups
d'État dans les pays du continent dans
lesquels la France entretient une
relation étroite et forte et qui ne
manque pas de nous interroger sur les
interprétations que nous pouvons en
tirer donc nous serons très heureux
d'avoir votre éclairage donc pour
mémoire au Niger le 26 juillet dernier
le général commandant la garde
présidentielle a engagé un putsch contre
le président bazoon et lui en 2021 cet
événement a profondément déstabilisé le
dispositif français de lutte contre le
terrorisme au Sahel et réarticuler
depuis le retrait contraint du Mali dont
nous pouvons peut-être parler également
depuis cet été la France soutient les
efforts de la Communauté des États
d'Afrique de l'Ouest la CEDEAO pour
favoriser un retour à l'ordre
constitutionnel au Niger
l'option militaire sans être privilégiée
ne nous semble pas complètement exclu
mais sans doute pourrez-vous nous en
dire davantage
toujours est-il qu'à mesure que l'action
des autorités Pucci s'inscrit dans la
durée notre pays se trouve de plus en
plus ciblé comme un bouquet mystère les
cinq accords bilatéraux de coopération
en matière de sécurité de défense ont
été dénoncés unilatéralement par les
puccistes qui instrumentalise des
manifestants contre nos forces sur place
de même notre ambassadeur dont je
souhaite saluer ici l'abnégation et la
résilience dans des circonstances aussi
difficiles a été déclaré persona non
grata par les autorités de fait donc
après avoir clairement donné une fin de
non-recevoir à ces injonctions le
président de la République tirant les
conséquences d'une situation dans
l'islement à annoncé le 24 septembre
dernier le retour à Paris de notre
ambassadeur et le retrait des forces
françaises stationnées au Niger
d'ici la fin de l'année donc sur ces
deux points madame la ministre nous
aimerions également que vous nous
apporter quelques précisions
enfin parce que il y a toujours beaucoup
d'actualité un mois à peine après les
événements au Niger un autre coup d'État
est intervenu au Gabon alors je ne vais
faire aucun parallèle entre les deux
événements parce que la réélection du
président Bongo suscité de nombreux
doutes et la population gabonaise aurait
peut-être faire de suppositions remis en
cause les résultats mais toujours est-il
que cela interroge sur la stabilité de
cette région du monde et bon le schéma
que vous connaissez mes chers collègues
le général commandant de la garde
républicaine et la jante ont beau jeu
faire valeur que l'armée gabonaise se
dévait de préserver la paix civile le
fait est qu'aujourd'hui ce pays dans une
situation de grande instabilité donc il
n'en demeure pas moins qu'à la
différence du Niger et d'autres pays du
Sahel exception faite de la Guinée le
cas du Gabon ne s'est pas illustré par
des manifestations hostiles à la France
ni par des revendications d'un départ
des symboles de l'État français qui
certes aussi une puissance coloniale
mais surtout un pays ami du Gabon et
prodiguant soutien substantiel face aux
défis colossaux que concerne ces pays du
peuple gabonais je devrais dire
peut-être
on a vu le Mali la Guinée le Burkina
Faso des putsch du Niger et du Gabon il
nous semble que tout cela traduit si ce
n'est une tendance ou encore une fois je
ne me risquerais pas à faire des
parallèles au moins un phénomène de fond
qui traverse ces populations qui
peut-être soit être davantage mettre de
leur destin peut-être cette aspiration
n'a pas suffisamment été décelé par la
France en tout cas nous serons très
intéressés par votre par votre point de
vue et par le retour que vous pouvez
avoir de nos équipes également sur le
terrain
donc des inquiétudes peuvent
légitimement naître vis-à-vis d'autres
pays comme le Cameroun le Congo ou même
peut-être luxad tout cela n'est pas
désespérant comme le montre le cas du
Sénégal dont le président a renoncé vous
le savez mes chers collègues et un
troisième mandat voilà je ne vais pas
m'attarder davantage parce que vous
l'avez vu mes chers collègues nous avons
un agenda très chargé et cependant
limité dans le temps Madame la Ministre
notre commission est donc impatiente de
connaître la lecture que vous faites de
ces faits ainsi que notre réseau
diplomatique je vous laisse sans plus
attendre la parole ensuite les orateurs
de groupe s'exprimeront pour 2 minutes
30 chacun essayons de rester dans les
délais je n'aime pas couper les
collègues mais si tout le monde joue le
jeu nous y arriverons et ensuite des
orateurs avec des questions
individuelles une minute une minute 10
je ne encore une fois je ne vous
couperai pas la parole mais la ministre
impérativement partir à 17h30 merci à
tous
merci infiniment madame la Présidente et
transmettez je vous prie et mes
félicitations et mes amitiés au
président bollange qui est empêché
aujourd'hui mes félicitations pour ça
réélection à la tête de cette commission
et je sais si cette occasion pour
féliciter également les nouveaux élus
parmi vous lorsque je ne les aurai pas
encore féliciter merci de l'initiative
de cette audition qui vient à point
nommer pour évoquer au moins deux des
situations qui en effet nous préoccupent
tous et qui sont d'actualité celles au
Sahel d'une part et celle dans le
Caucase d'autre pareil dans mes propos
introductifs je souhaiterais commencer
tout de suite par le coca si vous voulez
bien
j'étais hier à Erevan en effet madame la
vice-président je suis rentrée dans la
nuit et j'ai été après quelques mois
d'absence j'étais allé fin avril pour
manifester à nouveau l'amitié de la
France avec l'Arménie mais aussi au-delà
de cette amitié qui séculaire et
profonde son soutien et sa solidarité
dans l'épreuve que le gouvernement et le
peuple arménien traverse on a vu en
effet qu'en deux semaines ce sont sans
doute 100.000 Arméniens duo Karaba qui
ont dû fuir leur terre leur foyer et
trouver refuge
en Arménie après l'opération militaire
que vous avez évoquée déclenché par
l'Azerbaïdjan le 19 septembre et avec je
l'ai dit mais je le répète la complicité
de la Russie de tout
déroulant sous le regard je n'en dis pas
plus de la Turquie et ceci après 9 mois
d'un blocus illégal du correcteur de la
Chine par les forces azerbaïjanaises
illégal parce que on s'en souviendra la
Cour internationale de Justice dès le
mois de février avait un signe tranché
la situation et demander qu'il soit mis
un terme parce que lazerbaïdjan n'a pas
fait face à cette tragédie humanitaire
la réponse de la France sur le plan
humanitaire a été immédiate j'ai annoncé
que nous portions notre soutien de 5
millions d'euros à 12 millions d'euros
il est en réalité aujourd'hui de 12
millions d'euros déjà j'ai vu l'occasion
cet été de l'augmenter mais j'ai dû
l'augmenter encore sensiblement de façon
à aider
l'Arménie à accueillir ces réfugiés
déplacés dans des conditions de dignité
qui sont requises
ce soutien passera par le CICR j'ai
rencontré le responsable du CICR hier à
Erevan par nos eng présentent sur place
j'ai vu l'une d'entre elles et puis par
les dispositifs
nationaux Arméniens j'ai pu me rendre
dans un hôpital avec la ministre de la
Santé l'hôpital qui accueille une partie
des grands brûlés qui ont été
transportés du haut Karaba vers
Erevan
nous avons de même répondu tout de suite
pour envoyer une aide médicale d'urgence
après ce tragique incendie dans une
station-service près de Stéphane hacker
qui a fait plusieurs centaines de
victimes on le sait
cet accident terrible s'est déroulé le
25 septembre dès le 29 notre aide était
livré sur place elle est parvenue à bon
port très très rapidement
j'ai pu je le signaler me rendre hier
dans un hôpital qui accueillait certains
de ces grands brûlés et peut-être
l'avez-vous vu j'ai annoncé que quatre
grands blessés seront évacués par la
France
et c'est une opération que nous menons
avec mon collègue ministre de la Santé
je le remercie puisque ça permettra ces
quatre patients d'être accueillis et
traités dans des hôpitaux français mais
évidemment notre réponse n'est pas
humanitaire elle est surtout politique
bien entendu je veux redire ici parce
que
comment vous dire je ressens le besoin
de le répéter de le répéter encore que
la France est de loin le pays qui a fait
le plus et souvent
trop seul vous le savez pour
faire que la difficile situation dans
laquelle les Arméniens du yoga se
trouvaient soient mieux prises en compte
par la communauté internationale nous
avons agi aux Nations Unies trois
réunions du Conseil de sécurité ont eu
lieu chacune d'entre elles s'est tenue à
l'initiative de la France encore tout
récemment au mois de septembre lorsque
nous étions sur place en marge de
l'assemblée générale et a vendu la
demander après l'opération militaire de
l'Azerbaïdjan nous agissons aussi
toujours dans ce cadre des Nations Unies
pour avec nos partenaires américains
notamment créé les conditions si nous le
pouvons qui permettront de porter un
projet de résolution visant à garantir
une présence permanente des agences de
l'ONU au garaba et aussi à préserver le
droit qu'il faut réaffirmer le droit des
populations arméniennes du haut Karaba
celle qui le souhaiteront en tout cas à
revenir sur leur terre et à y vivre dans
le respect de leur histoire et de leur
culture
la démarche est en cours
je reste prudent vous le voyez dans mon
expression parce qu'il faut nous sommes
pas seuls au Conseil de sécurité il faut
à la fois assurer une majorité de voix
il faut éviter qu'il y ait des vétos la
France
agit dans d'autres enceintes ils
mettaient donné l'occasion encore hier
de le répéter l'OSCE nous avons œuvré au
sein de l'Union européenne nous avons
œuvré aussi cette initiative de la
France qu'une mission d'observation a pu
se déployer en territoire arménien j'y
reviendrai
nous serons
au-delà de la question du haut Karaba
proprement dit extrêmement vigilant face
à toute tentative de menacer la
souveraineté l'intégrité territoriale de
l'Arménie le président de la République
l'a dit avec clarté et fermeté
publiquement je les redis sur place
moi-même hier après lui
il y a presque un an jour bonjour à
Prague en marge de la première réunion
de la communauté politique européenne
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan avaient lors
d'une réunion qui se tenait à
l'initiative du Président de la
République et du président du Conseil
européen plus réaffirmer
leur soutien à l'intégrité territoriale
de chacun et au respect de l'intégrité
territoriale de l'autre nous voulons
nous assurer que cet engagement sera
respecté et bâtir sur cet engagement
pour aller plus loin c'est toute la
question qui se pose aujourd'hui dans le
prolongement de notre relation de
défense avec l'armée qui existe qui
n'est pas nouvelle peut-être avez-vous
vu les propos du ministre des Armées il
y a quelques jours puis les miens hier
indiquant que la France avait donné son
accord à la poursuite de l'acquisition
par l'Arménie de matériel
défensif pour
contribuer à sa protection c'est une
décision
inutile de le dire qui était nécessaire
alors que de son côté laser major n'a eu
de cesse que de s'armer pour
entreprendre des actions offensives et
pour mener de fait des actions
offensives nous agissons bien sûr dans
le prolongement de cette relation de
défense et faut-il le préciser avec
esprit de responsabilité et sans aucun
esprit d'escalade bien évidemment
en Arménie toujours et pour servir la
même logique politique nous renforçons
notre présence dans une région voisine
de les arbéjean qui s'appelle le sunnik
région frontalière Sud Est avec la
nomination
d'une ce sera une dame d'une consule
honoraire à Goris et avec
la volonté de renforcer notre relation
économique avec cette région avec un
certain nombre de grands projets
notamment sur le plan des
infrastructures j'en ai parlé hier avec
le président pachinian avec le Premier
ministre par nos pachinian de
l'infrastructure des transports de l'eau
de l'énergie un certain nombre de
projets existent d'ores et déjà
j'évoquais ce que nous avions pu faire
dans le cadre de l'Union européenne
en complément j'indique que j'ai demandé
officiellement par écrit donc aux
représentants de l'Union européenne de
renforcer à la fois les effectifs et la
mission et le mandat de cette mission
d'observation employée
à notre initiative sur le territoire
arménien et je lui ai demandé
également
d'inclure
l'Arménie dans la liste des
bénéficiaires de la ce qu'on appelle la
facilité européenne de paix comme on le
fait dans une situation un peu
comparable qui est celle de la Moldavie
qui est elle-même soumise certains de
tentatives et subit un certain nombre de
menaces
pour nous il nous plaidons sans relâche
en ce sens l'Union européenne doit
adresser un signal clair à tous ceux qui
pourraient être tentés de menacer
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Arménie et
je le redis toute action en ce sens
donnerait lieu à des réactions robustes
nous nous employons rassembler les
Européens sur cette ligne et nous
espérons aussi pouvoir compter sur le
soutien des États-Unis également pour
cela et puis vous avez pu entendre hier
je crois de la part de la première
ministre lors des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement que nous appelons à
bâtir un véritable plan européen d'appui
à une Arménie pour le futur indépendant
de souveraine et démocratique nous
cherchons je vous le redis à rallier
davantage de partenaires européens à nos
vues je veux aussi souligner comme j'ai
eu l'occasion de le faire hier
l'importance de la ratification par le
Parlement arménien de l'adhésion de ce
pays à la Cour pénale internationale
l'armée était signataire du Statut de
Rome vous n'avez pas ratifié pour
peut-être ménager ses relations avec la
Russie
elle vient de franchir ce pas important
que nous devons saluer qui est un
courageux et qui renforcera la lutte
contre l'impunité renforce son
positionnement dans le camp de ceux qui
recherchent la paix puisque il n'y a pas
de paix sans justice
vous le constatez mesdames et messieurs
les députés madame la vice-présidente la
France ne ménage pas ses efforts et
poursuivra ses efforts n'a pas attendu
hier pour le faire et pour s'intéresser
à l'Arménie comme à la préservation des
droits des populations vivants au Caraba
et je voudrais souligner
que par ma présence hier à irvan nous
avons été le premier pays
à avoir un membre du gouvernement se
rendant sur le sol arménien depuis le
déclenchement de l'opération militaire
azerbaïdjanaise
j'encourage j'ai encouragé lors de la
réunion de lundi nous étions tous
ensemble
tous mes collègues des 27 États membres
à se rendre eux aussi en armée dans les
jours et dans les semaines qui viennent
donc dans cette région comme ailleurs la
France reste à l'initiative quelques
mots en introduction également sur la
situation au Sahel et plus précisément
sur la plus complexe d'entre elles
peut-être qui est la situation au Niger
l'effet vous les avez rappelé madame la
vice-présence c'est le renversement le
26 juillet par
poignée de généraux en général rejoint
ensuite par d'autres d'un Président d'un
président élu démocratiquement par son
peuple et qui de plus mener des réformes
courageux obtenez
des succès sur le plan économique obtenu
des succès dans le domaine de la lutte
contre les groupes armées terroristes
également et mener une action courageuse
et peut-être qu'il lui a coûté de lutte
contre la corruption le président Bazoom
est toujours détenues en otage avec son
épouse et son fils c'est inacceptable et
de plus détenu dans des conditions qui
sont absolument
inadmissibles et le mot
otage est pleinement justifié dans son
cas
face à cette tentative de putsch la
réaction de la communauté internationale
a été ferme et unanime les Nations Unies
l'Union africaine la CEDEAO les
principaux partenaires du Niger l'Union
européenne des États-Unis
jean-citre et d'autres s'il fallait
poursuivre la liste tous exigent la
libération du Président Bazoom et le
retour à l'ordre constitutionnel
la CEDEAO en particulier qui est en
première ligne il s'agit des pays
voisins du Niger a pris des mesures
fermes pour faire plier la jinthe
notamment à travers des sanctions
financières et économiques lourdes
inhabituellement lourdes de magie et qui
ont été d'application immédiate et aussi
pour les appuyer à travers la
possibilité
du recours à une opération
militaire régionale s'il le fallait
les pays de la région ne volent pas que
ce putsch réussisse
parce que au-delà de la fragilisation du
Sahel dont on a vu déjà quelques
exemples au-delà même du rôle clé du
rôle pivot distille souvent du Niger
dans la lutte antiterroriste ils sont
inquiets de l'effet domino que vous
rappeliez madame la Présidente et des
conséquences que cela pourrait avoir sur
toute la région et peut-être même
jusqu'au Golf de Guinée
en soutien aux initiatives de la CEDEAO
la France a été au rendez-vous depuis le
premier jour et je crois que c'est toute
son honneur nous avons suspendu
immédiatement l'ensemble de nos
coopérations civiles et militaires nous
avons refusé de tempérer lorsque la
jointe a demandé le départ de notre
ambassadeur et le départ de nos forces
nous n'avons pas à obéir aux injonctions
d'un pouvoir illégal illégitime et nous
avons continué de marquer notre soutien
au président Bazoum et à la CEDEAO
de plus à Bruxelles et après la réunion
informelle des 27 le Gimme niche de
Tolède de fin août nous avons lancé des
discussions pour l'adoption de sanctions
européennes contre les puccistes
nouveau cadre de sanction qui devrait
être mis en place d'ici la fin de ce
mois les choses progressent bien
j'insiste sur un fait parce que on a
entendu ou lui il a aussi un certain
nombre de choses peu exactes c'est la
Cedeo qui est en première ligne c'est la
Cedeo et les pays de la région les pays
voisins du Niger qui sont les premiers
concernés et c'était elle qui est à la
manœuvre si je puis dire pour faire
plier la jinte par la négociation
assortie de ces deux leviers que je
rappelais tout à l'heure la France pour
sa part elle est à l'écoute des pays de
la région elle vient en appui de leurs
efforts et on appuie des efforts de la
Cedeo et à leur demande
je vais rappeler aussi que le 30 juillet
notre ambassade a subi une attaque
manifestement organisée violente
extrêmement violente même et en
conséquence de cela nous avons décidé
d'évacuer nos ressortissants du Niger
ainsi que la plupart de nos agents
hormis l'ambassadeur et un tout petit
nombre de collaborateurs qui sont restés
autour de lui grâce à la mobilisation du
centre de crise et de soutien de mon
ministère grâce à cette ambassade grâce
à celle de nos armées nous sommes
parvenus en deux jours à rapatrier plus
de 1000 personnes
1079 personnes dont une grosse moitié de
français ils étaient 577 et des
ressortissants de 50 autres nationalités
donc comme au Soudan une solidarité
concrète qui n'est pas que européenne
d'ailleurs et qui est aussi à l'honneur
de la France nous avons reçu beaucoup de
remerciements de la part de pays qui ont
pu ainsi mettre à l'abri le
ressortissant de plus notre ambassade
et au-delà d'elle d'autres d'ailleurs
vous le verrez a subi pendant deux mois
environ des violations multiples et
répétés de la Convention de Vienne son
approvisionnement a été empêché c'est
une violation de convention de Vienne
les véhicules diplomatiques ont été
fouillés autre violation des
ambassadeurs européens qui rendaient
visitent à notre ambassadeur ce sont
même vus interdire de lui rendre visite
et non pas pu accéder jusqu'à lui autres
violations de leur privilège et immunité
diplomatique donc ces violations ne
concerne pas que la France
et
tout ceci
a conduit le 24 septembre
devant
le constat que la présence de nos forces
n'avait plus d'utilité dans un pays où
la coopération militaire avait été
suspendue près de deux mois
précédemment le président de la
République a annoncé à la fois le
retrait progressif de nos forces armées
et le rappel de notre ambassadeur qui
est rentrée à Paris vous l'avez vu il y
a quelques jours nos forces armées
mènent des discussions techniques en ce
moment avec la jointe pour assurer ce
retrait en sécurité
pour autant je voudrais
être très clair ce retrait nécessaire
puisque nos forces armées étaient là à
la demande d'un gouvernement
démocratique
élu légitimement représentant la volonté
de son peuple et pour assurer une
mission particulière qui était l'appui à
la lutte antiterroriste alors que les
bouddhistes n'ont rien de légitime et ne
lutte pas contre le terrorisme cette
décision nécessaire ne signifie en rien
un changement de position de fond nous
soutenons le président Bazoum nous
demandons sa libération nous continuons
de soutenir les efforts de la CEDEAO et
si elle devait nous demander de
poursuivre nous poursuivrions je veux
que ce soit tout à fait clair on reste
d'ailleurs en contact étroit régulier à
tout niveau avec nos partenaires de la
CEDEAO de l'Union Africaine dont je
recevais le président de la commission
avec quelques jours avec évidemment nos
partenaires européens avec lesquels nous
parlons beaucoup du Sahel et avec les
États-Unis qui ont un rôle clé comme on
l'a vu pour unir nos efforts autant
qu'il est possible et faire échouer ce
coup d'État pour que l'ordre
constitutionnel revienne au Niger il
faut continuer de penser qu'il peut
revenir parce que c'est essentiel pour
la démocratie dans la région mais aussi
pour la stabilité du Sahel si j'élargi
un peu en répondant à votre invitation
madame Davis Présidente il faut bien
dire que la situation de sécurité au
Sahel
n'a jamais été aussi mauvaise c'est
putsch en réalité sont catastrophiques
pour les populations et ceux qui portent
leurs critiques sur la France et sur les
gouvernements démocratiques africains
d'ailleurs pour dissimuler leur propre
échecs en la matière serait bien de s'en
souvenir au Niger on a vu que les
attaques terroristes ont
considérablement augmenté depuis que
nous
ne agissons plus et depuis que eux-mêmes
n'agissent pas les attaques terroristes
se multiplient on a vu encore cette
semaine ce qu'il en était
depuis le retrait de barkhane
n'étions pas seul je le rappelle le Mali
se dit tout à la fois une extension sans
précédent des territoires contrôlés par
les groupes armées terroristes et voix
une reprise de la guerre avec les
groupes armés du Nord avec une
composante ethnique qui ne cesse bien
sûr de préoccuper et pour sa part le
Burkina continue de s'enfoncer dans une
crise sécuritaire et humanitaire dont on
parle sans doute trop peu qui est
elle-même dramatique
et enfin
rappelons que tout ceci se produit alors
que les gens ne respectent pas les
calendriers de transition qui ont été
mis au point qu'ils avaient accepté et
empêche donc tout retour à la démocratie
toute perspective d'amélioration de la
situation
c'est dans ce contexte
de dégradation et je dirais même de
dégradation brutale des conditions de
sécurité que nous avons été contraints
de classer en zone ce qu'on appelle en
zone rouge donc en zone où nous
demandons aux Français de ne pas se
rendre les deux pays concernés je
rappelle que nous l'avons fait déjà pour
d'autres pays mais je voudrais aussi
rappeler que au Burkina Faso notre
ambassade aussi avait été l'objet
d'assaut comme nos instituts français il
y a un peu plus d'un an et parce que
nous sommes responsables de la sécurité
de nos agents et je veux rendre bien sûr
un hommage particulier à notre
ambassadeur au Niger mais aussi à toute
l'équipe qui restait avec lui jusqu'au
bout de même qu'à nos équipes dans ces
pays qui sont rarement cités par ceux
qui commentent assez confortablement les
choses depuis Paris la décision était
prise de faire rentrer une partie de nos
personnels dans ces pays et l'ensemble
des familles pour qu'elles ne soient pas
exposées
et donc de réduire le format de nos
ambassades comme on dit réduire leur
capacité d'action
cette décision a eu pour conséquence de
rendre plus difficile
ne fait mise voir même de suspendre une
partie de nos actions de coopération sur
place dans ces trois pays et j'insiste
bien je dis bien sur place pour préciser
que les artistes les chercheurs les
scientifiques
les étudiants sont toujours les
bienvenus en France dans les
institutions culturelles comme dans nos
universités et contrairement à ce que
j'ai pu lire ou est-ce que vous avez pu
lire ici ou là et n'a jamais été
question qu'il en soit autrement de fait
ils sont là et il y a 6700 étudiants ces
trois pays aujourd'hui en mobilité
en France et c'est poursuivent leurs
études plusieurs centaines d'entre eux
bénéficient d'ailleurs de bourse
d'études du gouvernement français et
donc là aussi mettons les choses là où
elles sont et soyons faire fiers de ce
que nous faisons parce que aucun pays
n'en fait autant pour les jeunesses du
sel et pour
ces personnes que nous avons sur notre
territoire et dont nous contribuons je
l'espère à faire croître la
compréhension pour ce que nous faisons
du fait du format réduit nos ambassades
nous avons été aussi contraints de
suspendre la délivrance normale des
visas donc dans les prochaines semaines
quand le format des ambassades sera
stabilisé nous pourrons réévaluer les
conditions de sécurité qu'il faut
regarder très soigneusement de façon à
ajuster au mieux les mesures qui ont été
prises permettez-moi de souligner que
nous continuerons donc d'accorder des
visas tandis que le Burkina ne délivre
toujours pas de visa à plusieurs de nos
agents qui devraient rejoindre leur
poste et bien sûr nous maintenons notre
aide humanitaire nous n'abandons de ne
pas les plus vulnérables et c'était du
méditérité est importante puisque pour
ces trois pays elle s'élevait l'an
dernier à près de 60 millions d'euros je
crois que nous sommes fidèles à nos
valeurs en restant aux côtés des
populations qui souffrent en alertant
sur les errements de leur dirigeants
aussi alors nous renversons pas les
responsabilités ce sont les gens qui
rendent la coopération difficile avec
nous et pas la France avec leur pays
et par ailleurs je terminerai par là ce
propos introductif la situation au sel
avec
trois jantes militaires qui
instrumentalisent leur oscillité la
France pour cacher leur forfait ne doit
pas
occulter je le dis je le redis
l'ensemble de notre relation avec
l'Afrique le continent africain est
vaste il est divers l'Afrique ne se
résume pas au Sahel et avec l'immense
majorité des 54 pays africains nos
relations sont très bonnes et souvent au
même en voie de progression je le
constate d'ailleurs moi-même à chaque
fois que je me déplace sur le continent
africain un Éthiopie en Afrique du Sud
en Côte d'Ivoire
prochainement au Cameroun et au nigérien
la France est un pays attractif et
influent dans la grande majorité des
pays africains nos entreprisions
progressé s'il vous plaît voyez là aussi
l'arrêter comme elle est et sans
défaitisme en 15 ans nos investissements
doublés
le nombre de filets de nos entreprises
également et notamment nos petites et
moyennes entreprises nous sommes devenus
le second investisseur étranger sur le
continent africain nos universités nos
écoles je le disais récemment dans
l'hémicycle je crois attire toujours
plus d'étudiants africains
depuis 2017 40% de plus et ils sont
aujourd'hui 92000 à étudier dans notre
pays et grâce à la mobilisation de nos
ambassades nous voulons continuer cette
trajectoire
ascendante
un dernier rappel ou deux derniers
appels
le premier pour vous faire mesurer que
depuis 2017 jamais la France n'a autant
investi dans l'émergence du continent
africain notre APD est passé de 10
milliards plus de 15 milliards d'euros
15 milliards d'euros par an dont un gros
tiers est consacré à l'Afrique nous
sommes devenus le quatrième bailleur
international
devant son en 2022 le Royaume-Uni et
surtout nous sommes le seul pays dont
les investissements solidaires ont
progressé en Afrique le seul pays autre
vérité que je voudrais rappeler nous
finançons des projets dans la santé
l'éducation la formation professionnelle
les infrastructures l'adaptation au
changement climatique l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes une bonne part
de notre aide publique au développement
à cette finalité nous finançons aussi le
développement du secteur privé avec un
effort particulier sur les PME des
startups innovantes j'en vois souvent
leur potentiel est remarquable et faux
et des cette partie là
des pays africains avec lesquels nous
avons de bonnes relations nous
accompagnons aussi nos diaspora quand
elles veulent investir sur le continent
je pense qu'il y aurait beaucoup à
développer à ce titre et nous soutenons
une éducation francophone de qualité en
formant chaque année parce que pour qui
était francophone il faut qu'il y ait
des enseignants
s'expriment en français nous formons
chaque année plus de 20
000 enseignants en français
et enfin dernier rappel s'il y a bien
une priorité française dans ses
relations avec les pays africains
aujourd'hui c'est de travailler avec eux
en partenariat d'égal à égal pour
rénover la gouvernance mondiale gérer
ensemble le défi commun faire prévaloir
ce que nous pouvons faire ensemble nous
l'avons fait pendant le covid en livrant
des médicaments en installant des
capacités de production dans des pays
africains de vaccins nous l'avons fait
en Afrique centrale avec le sommier sur
les forêts à Libreville nous le faisons
en ce moment avec le Kenya pour trouver
des solutions pour financer la
transition écologique et c'était pour
résumer tout le sens du sommet de Paris
pour un nouveau pacte financier mondial
pour affronter ensemble et de front
l'enjeu du développement et celui de la
transition ne pas avoir à choisir entre
les deux sur les 120 ou 130 pays
présents il y avait
pays africain représenter au niveau des
chefs d'État je crois que c'est le signe
et de leur intérêt et de leur
compréhension que nous pouvons faire des
choses ensemble et donc alors que notre
système
multilatéral fondé sur la règle de droit
n'a jamais été aussi menacé alors que
les briques s'élargient alors que
certains pays
veulent jouer sur la fragmentation du
monde nous travaillons avec nos
partenaires africains pour
rebâtir une gouvernance mondiale plus
résiliente plus juste et qui nous
permettent de trouver ensemble les
solutions un certain nombre de défis
commun ça passe par une meilleure place
de l'Afrique dans la gouvernance
internationale nous avons déjà pu faire
en sorte pas seul mais la France était à
la pointe de ce combat que l'Union
africaine soit admise comme membre à
part entière au G20 nous militons pour
une réforme du Conseil de sécurité nous
espérons qu'elle puisse progresser dans
les institutions financières
internationales et je dis ça à quelques
jours des réunions de Marrakech
du famille et de la Banque mondiale et
nous poursuivrons voilà Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la
vice-présidente
j'arrête cette introduction en appelant
à nouveau à la justice
mais au refus du défaitisme parce que le
défaitisme ne correspondrait pas à la
réalité des relations que nous avons
avec l'Afrique
merci merci beaucoup madame les
ministres merci merci d'avoir rappelé
tous ces faits mais aussi d'avoir
apporté quelques précisions qui étaient
nécessaires après l'été agité que nous
avons eu sur le plan des relations
internationales et puis la rentrée qui
n'était pas plus calme d'ailleurs donc
je pense que la Commission apprécie
cette introduction très très détaillée
nous allons maintenant donner la parole
aux différents orateurs de groupes alors
une fois n'est pas coutume comme je mets
un point d'honneur à ce que chacun
puisse s'exprimer et surtout vous
interroger nous allons commencer par les
derniers sur ma liste nous allons
commencer par le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire car
l'orateur du groupe liotte Monsieur
Bertrand penché a un empêchement donc
mes collègues vous m'excuserez cette cet
écart à notre règle l'important c'est
que vous puissiez avoir la parole je
vous en prie chers collègues je voulais
remercier chers collègues de me laisser
parler avant tout le monde j'ai un
rendez-vous avec j'ai un rendez-vous
avec un rendez-vous avec un membre du
gouvernement
dans quelques dans quelques minutes
j'en ai la deuxième
merci merci
comment je ne doute pas que beaucoup de
nos collègues vont vous interroger sur
la situation de l'Arménie exprimée
évidemment toute ma solidarité aussi au
nom du groupe ou non du groupe pilote en
direction du peuple arménien je voudrais
concentrer mes propos madame le ministre
sur la crise au sel et en Afrique on a
malheureusement l'impression que notre
pays est chassé partout d'Afrique en
commençant par le Maroc avec des des
relations particulièrement compliquées
beaucoup de pays
africains africains francophones et je
voulais revenir rapidement sur la crise
au Niger 7 coups d'État au Niger depuis
l'existence de ce pays et encore lors
d'un coup d'État la garde présidentielle
s'est retournée sur le président un
président de la République et là comment
malheureusement pas pour ça que nous
avons rompu toute les relations
diplomatiques avec le pays grand ami de
la France et d'ailleurs si nous rompions
toutes nos relations diplomatiques avec
tous les tyrans et dictateurs du monde
ça permettrait de reconcentrer notre
diplomatie sur malheureusement peu de
comment peu de peu de pays bon nous
avons montré nos muscles voulu montrer
nos muscles entraîner la CEDEAO et
venons de partir en étant chassé de ce
pays toujours amis de la France
donnons une image catastrophique de
notre diplomatie à la fois en direction
de ce pays qui reste amis de la France
et nigériens et puis surtout surtout en
Afrique dans une image d'un préparation
la plus totale
quel était réellement votre objectif et
sur le base sur la base de quel
fondement et comment expliquer vous ce
qui apparaît quand même comme étant
comme étant un désastre
on nous dit d'ailleurs que la diplomatie
et non militaire voulait continuer à
maintenir un minimum de relation avec ce
pays comme c'est toujours la tradition
quand il y a malheureusement des coups
d'État est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est
la réalité deuxième observation cette
politique contribue à affamé le peuple
merci beaucoup le peuple du Niger 30%
d'inflation plus de Franc CFA plus
d'aide comment puis l'aide au
développement est-ce que vous avez
conscience qu'on va mettre toute la
population nigérienne ado si rien n'est
réglé merci beaucoup
merci monsieur le député il y a beaucoup
de questions dans votre question donc je
glisserai rapidement pour dire
qu'évidemment je ne vais pas comparer
mais vous n'avez pas fait le Maroc et
des régimes putschistes je crois que
j'ai pas besoin de poursuivre non nous
n'avons pas entraîné la CEDEAO monsieur
le député je l'ai dit nous avons été aux
côtés nous continuons d'être côté de la
CEDEAO à sa demande et je le répète nous
continuerons à soutenir ces efforts quel
objectif là aussi je
crois l'avoir dit dans mon propos
introductif nos forces armées étaient
présentes au Niger à la demande
d'autorité légitime démocratiquement
élue et pour exercer une mission précise
qui était la mission d'appuyer la lutte
antiterroriste mission qui ne peut pas
ne peut plus s'exercer depuis le 26
juillet et dont il est évidemment
faut-il le dire hors de question qu'elle
s'exerce avec des généraux pulcisses qui
retiennent le président démocratiquement
élu en otage donc le président de la
République on a tiré les conséquences
logiquement avec l'annonce qui a été
faite le 24 septembre
merci madame la ministre je donne
maintenant la parole pour le groupe
Renaissance à mon collègue Adrien gomier
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre en préambule je sais que mon
collègue Didier reprendra la parole par
la suite mais je tenais à vous féliciter
au nom du groupe renaissance pour les
annonces que vous avez faites les
annonces importantes que vous avez fait
dans le cadre de votre déplacement à
Erevan aussi bien sur l'accord de
défense pour la livraison de matériel
militaire que sur l'appel à Joseph Borel
pour que la FP soit attribuée à
l'Arménie je tenais à vous remercier
vous l'avez rappelé le 26 juillet le
président du Niger Mohammed Bazoum était
renversé par un coup d'État militaire le
Conseil national pour la sauvegarde de
la patrie CNSP c'est alors installé au
pouvoir et donc après le Mali et le
Burkina Faso le Niger connaît à son tour
une période d'instabilité une situation
dont profite la Russie qui mène une
opportuniste propagande de
désinformation anti-française aussi bien
sûr les réseaux sociaux que dans les
médias propagande dont les populations
locales seront à terme les principales
victimes avec la milice Wagner comme
bras armée la Russie continue d'étendre
son influence en Afrique la France et
vous l'avez dit a condamné justement le
putsch est appelé au retour immédiat de
Mohamed Bazoum à la tête du pays une
position ferme que notre majorité a
toujours soutenu
quelques semaines plus tard un autre
coup d'État militaire a eu lieu cette
fois-ci au Gabon nous avons comme au
Niger condamné le putsch mené par les
militaires en dénonçant un coup de force
survenu en plein processus électoral
quelques heures après la proclamation
contestée de la réélection d'Ali Bongo
contrairement à ce que certains
sous-entendent et comme la rappeler
notre Présidente nous devons distinguer
ce putsch de celui survenu au Niger la
coopération militaire avec notre pays et
l'aide au développement ayant été
maintenu alors kanyamet les militaires
puccistes ont rapidement lancé une
violente campagne anti-française le
président Emmanuel Macron a officialisé
le retrait de notre route présente au
Niger
pour rappel la France compte entre 1000
et 1500 soldats dans ce pays devenus
suite au départ du Mali courant 2022 la
pièce centrale de notre nouveau
dispositif anti djihadiste dans la
région les troupes françaises y sont
répartis sur trois sites la base
aérienne projetée 101 à Niamey celle de
wallam et celle d'ayuru ce dispositif
français au Niger visa jusque là à
fournir un appui feu et du renseignement
à l'armée nigérienne récolter notamment
lors de vols de surveillance la fin de
cette coopération militaire avec les
autorités du Niger implique le fait que
nous ne pourrons plus lutter aussi
efficacement qu'auparavant contre le
terrorisme ce départ exclut une soldat
français de la zone des trois frontières
et puissante de l'activité des groupes
terroristes ainsi madame la ministre
avec cette nouvelle situation
géopolitique comment voyez-vous l'avenir
de notre action militaire contre le
terrorisme au Sahel je vous remercie je
vous remercie chers collègues madame
merci merci Madame la vice-présente
merci monsieur le député Gomis
vous avez évoqué le Gabon je crois qu'il
faut dire rapidement que dans le cas du
Gabon comme dans le cas du Niger comme
toujours nous sommes à l'écoute des pays
de la région je le dis et de ce que
décide des organisations régionales
lesquelles pour concerne le Gabon n'ont
pas décidé de sanctions vous le savez et
donc nous sommes là aussi sur la même
ligne au demeurant évidemment le
processus électoral était contesté vous
le savez là où on Niger un président
légitimement et démocratiquement élu
avait été
retenu
otage je ne veux pas considérer que le
pot de chat réussie par cela même qui
est essentiel de protéger alors sur le
retrait de notre couple
la mission qui était la leur ne peut
plus être assurée depuis le 26 juillet
et je leur dis il n'est pas question de
coopérer militairement avec des puces
dont nous demandons par ailleurs qu'il
veut bien
mettre fin alors tentative et restaurer
l'ordre constitutionnel donc nos 1500
militaires présents au Niger ne peuvent
plus exercer leur mission et la
conséquence en évidemment la décision du
Président de la République rendu public
le 24 septembre je veux d'ailleurs
rendre hommage à nos militaires à ceux
qui ont agi efficacement au Niger avec
les résultats avérés qui étaient les
leurs tout comme il faut rendre hommage
à tous ceux qui au Mali et ailleurs ont
perdu la vie pour mener la lutte
antiterroriste et ont eu de bons
résultats sur le terrain alors
évidemment le retrait de nos forces
militaires réduit la contribution de la
France à la lutte contre les terrorisme
en Afrique de l'Ouest et pour que
d'autres n'en profitent pas j'ai bien
entendu ce que vous disiez monsieur le
député nous aurons dans les semaines qui
viennent avec les européens mais aussi
avec les États-Unis d'Amérique et avec
les pays de la CEDEAO le besoin de mener
un dialogue approfondi sur la façon
maintenant de gérer au mieux ce défi
alors que nous ne sommes plus au Niger
et c'est une décision dont je ne vois
pas comment elle ne serait pas comprise
il est hors de question de coopérer
militairement avec des régimes puccistes
merci madame la ministre et notre
commission restauratrez attentive à
l'évolution de ces discussions et nous
aurons je l'espère l'occasion de d'en
reparler maintenant je veux passer la
parole pour le rassemblement national à
Monsieur Michel Guignot
oui bonjour merci madame la Présidente
même la ministre d'affaires étrangères
je commencerai tout d'abord sur le
permettez par le Niger au hiver la
présence des diplomatiques françaises
est assurée depuis l'indépendance de ce
pays depuis le 3 août 1960 le pays a été
dit tout à l'heure a été déjà malmené
par des puccistes ça semble être une
spécialité locale puisque écoute 74 99
2002 2007-2009 2010 et enfin peut-être
2023 ce dernier a toutefois remis en
cause la présence diplomatique militaire
mais aussi économique de la France au
Niger l'armée en particulier le général
titanie a choisi de s'opposer à la
présence française alors jusqu'en rotule
retenir en otage ou quasiment poussant
le président de la République a annoncé
le retrait étoupe française et la fin de
la représentation diplomatique française
sur place lors de son passage au Gabon
en mars 2023 le président de la
République avait commencé à écouter de
l'effacement en présence française au
profit de l'action de l'Union européenne
en mai dernier les autorités françaises
avaient annoncé une réduction de moitié
de la présence militaire française d'ici
2024 le 2 octobre on va s'adapte de
France au Gabon annoncé la session de
son consulat général à Libreville les
deux agences consulaires françaises
françaises sont domiciliés dans des
hôtels alors que la France ça pourrait
être manifestement à partir le régime
républicain gabonais fait l'objet d'un
coup d'État dynastiques depuis la
Finlande la France par la voie de la
première ministre ne s'est engagée qu'à
suivre la situation avec la plus grande
attention cela a été elle dit aussi tout
à l'heure le groupe du Rassemblement
national est favorable bien sûr à
l'expression des droits nationaux dans
le but de consolider la démocratie dans
le monde mais dans les cas précisés la
démocratie la démocratie serait plutôt
en danger comment mesurer l'attachement
que nous avons envers des pays pour
lesquels nous avons contribué fortement
financièrement depuis des décennies pour
lesquelles des soldats français ont mis
leur en danger quelle politique
africaine cohérente allez-vous pouvoir
mener face aux réactions que notre
drapeau suscite quel sera donc notre
politique vis-à-vis de ces événements
allons-nous continuer à subventionner
ces pays je ne parle pas des soutiens
aux associations humanitaires la France
sera-t-elle présente pour les aider à se
relever chez eux ou les populations
opprimées devront-elles migrer jusqu'à
chez nous pour chercher la sécurité le
soutien dont elles ont besoin enfin à la
suite de la modification de l'ordre du
jour et de votre déplacement
d'administes en Arménie pouvez-vous nous
éclairer sur la persécution des
populations chrétiennes par Azerbaïdjan
la dissolution contrainte de la
République du locabac au profit de
l'Azerbaïdjan ainsi que sur les contrats
qui seront faits avec l'Arménie pour
assurer sa défense et de quelle sorte de
contrat et d'armement la France est-elle
supposée livrée merci chers collègues
alors j'ai essayé de compter toutes les
questions ils m'ont bloqué il y en a à
peu près 10 mais je vais laisser madame
la ministre vous répondre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député j'ai fait rendez-vous de vous
répondre dans le temps qui m'est compté
donc de façon peut-être qui vous
paraîtra lapidaire mais qui vous aidera
à comprendre la situation j'en forme le
jeu nous n'avons pas rompu nos relations
diplomatiques avec le Niger et nous
n'avons pas non plus fermé notre
ambassade ambassade reste ouverte avec
une toute petite équipe à la différence
par exemple de ce que nous avons dû
faire au Soudan au Afghanistan donc il
n'y a pas d'effacement j'ai donné
quelques chiffres sur l'Afrique et nos
relations avec la quasi totalité des
pays africains qui montre une
progression qui est
avérée si l'on veut bien regarder les
faits les putsch échoueront je ne
connais pas de putsch qui est mené son
pays sur la voie du développement comme
il le faudrait donc je veux croire
évidemment comme vous-même ce débutez
dans la résilience des modèles
démocratiques et leur plus grande
efficacité l'histoire aussi puisque vous
reliez à la rescousse le montre assez
largement quant au Gabon on parlait
d'effacement est
absurde la France est extrêmement
présente au Gabon
25% des emplois privés au Gabon par
exemple viennent des entreprises
françaises et je rappelais tout à
l'heure en rappelant la densité de nos
relations avec la plupart des pays
africains que l'investissement de nos
entreprises il y a cru considérablement
et qu'en particulier nous nous
réjouissons beaucoup de la présence plus
forte encouragée par notre diplomatie
des petites et moyennes entreprises
qu'il y avait peu l'habitude d'être
présente sur le continent africain notre
politique et ce qu'elle est ambitieuse
volontariste et le sentiment
anti-français n'est pas du tout une
donnée dominante elle est peut-être dans
l'esprit de quelques Pucci qui
instrumentalise
des critiques un endroit de notre pays
alors qui conduisent leur peuple et leur
pays dans la difficulté j'observe aussi
mais vous l'avez vu que c'est
agitations
anti-françaises avec force drapeau russe
viennent souvent dans un second temps ne
sont pas la motivation des populations
ni même la motivation du putsch que ces
généraux mènent
ensuite apparaissent d'autres drapeaux
que le nôtre je vous laisse conclure
merci merci Madame la Ministre
maintenant pour le la France insoumise
nous avons notre collègue Arnaud Le Gal
merci Madame présidente merci madame la
ministre je crois que l'heure est venue
de faire un bilan de l'action en Afrique
il y a 9 ans maintenant lors du passage
de Serval à barkhane beaucoup de doutes
avaient été émis par des responsables
politiques français des doutes qui sont
consultables encore public en raison du
manque de consolidation politique de
l'intervention d'une forme d'aveuglement
face aux dimensions politiques
économique sociale écologique de la
crise saélienne et face aux échecs
flagrants au manque d'enseignement les
déchets flagrants de certaines guerres
asymétriques comme celles menées par les
États-Unis en Afghanistan
et puis au fur et à mesure que la France
initialement accueillie en sauveur
notamment au Mali j'ai même souvenir que
vous été très injustement mais c'est un
fait était pointé comme responsable de
tous les mots nombre d'observateurs et
d'acteurs politiques ont alerté sur la
nécessité d'en tirer certaines
conclusions mais il y a jamais eu de
débats pendant des années on nous a dit
barkhane est un succès alors que malgré
les succès tactiques et je rends hommage
ici comme tous à nos soldats et en
particulier à ceux qui ont perdu la vie
on ne pouvait pas se succéder à qui ne
pouvait pas masquer le fait que les
groupes armés violentes y a 10 ou non se
multiplier avant les coups d'État je
suis d'accord avec vous la situation
s'aggrave depuis mais c'est il se
multiplie déjà avant les coups d'État et
pendant barcan
malgré ses alertes quant à la colère
croissante des populations face au
régime locaux et colère qui
rejaillissaient sur notre pays qui était
vu comme un soutien assez régime on a
fermé les yeux jusqu'au coup d'état
coup d'État dénoncé à juste titre mais
quand dans le même temps on allait à
douber quelqu'un comme le fils des
billes au Tchad
et on nous disait là-bas vous êtes des
hypocrites
et au lieu de tirer les enseignements de
tout cela
l'Elysée
que d'Orsay mais surtout l'Elysée c'est
enfermé dans des explications faciles la
propagande russe aussi grossière
soit-elle et qui n'est pas nouvelle
était vu comme l'explication de tout
alors que le vrai sujet c'était comment
se fait-il que les populations ont une
partie d'entre elles soient perméable à
cette propagande grossière
etc en définitive voilà notre pays qui
donne une situation difficile dans une
zone importante
et on a vu les choses venir depuis des
années il y a jamais eu de débat alors
la séquence du Niger vient d'achever ou
pas d'ailleurs on a on a dit on tient
bon tiens bon on tient bon on partira
pas on partira pas en partira pas puis
du jour au lendemain on part
comment se fait-il que cette séquence a
été gérée de cette manière en termes de
communication et je terminerai juste en
lisant un passage d'une cinquantaine de
chercheurs d'ONG de la style française
et saélia etc qui écrivait en 2021 nous
n'attendons pas de la France qu'elle
trouve seule des solutions défi du sel
mais elle peut elle doit se tenir une
autre processus de reconstruction qui
prennent en compte les aspirations des
sahéniens les sahéliennes pas seulement
celle de ceux qui les dirigent la fin
programmée de barkham doit être
l'occasion de faire émerger un débat sur
l'avenir du rôle de la France dans la
région et de demander des comptes sur
les choix politiques pris ces dernières
années je fais mienne cette question
[Musique]
vous parlez beaucoup de débats c'est
précisément ce que nous avons ici un
débat et je laisse donc la ministre
répondre
c'est bien merci monsieur le député Le
Gall vous me permettez de redire que
barkham est un succès c'est un succès
sur le plan militaire qui était sa
mission et je ne pense pas que vous
pensiez plus que moi qu'il appartiennent
à la France de faire la politique des
pays africains et les difficultés que
vous soulevez sont réelles au demeurant
je crois que notre pays en attiré les
conséquences avec les décisions que je
rappelais tout à l'heure la dimension
politique bien sûr a été prise en compte
par l'ensemble des partenaires de ces
pays je rappellerai que les accords
d'Algés existés qu'ils ont été remis en
cause par la jante et que
à la minute si je puis dire où nous
sommes partis le terrorisme a explosé
certes s'il préexister il était combattu
et il progresse depuis que nous ne
sommes plus là je parlais tout à l'heure
de l'exemple du Niger depuis le
26 juillet et il y a eu plus de morts
suite à des attaques terroristes donc en
deux mois quand deux ans présidente
Bazoum voilà s'il fallait la mesure de
la chose quand au sentiment t'il
français c'est un peu plus un autre je
ne l'encourage pas plus que vous mais
trouver un coupable extérieur à des
comportements anticonstitutionnels et
légitime je crois que il n'en
il n'en sortira rien de bon je le redis
vous avez aussi par les du Tchad au
Tchad je ne crois pas vous avoir jamais
dit ce que vous dites que nous aurions
dit nous avons pris avec du fait qu'il y
avait un président de transition et je
redis volontiers que nous espérons que
cette transition se pleinement respectée
j'ai parlé du Gabon tout à l'heure et
oui il faut une transition dans le cas
du Gabon également enfin
vous ne nous avez sans doute pas bien
écouté monsieur député permettez moi ce
reproche puisque vous me faites
quelques-uns vous ferez au moins
celui-là la France n'a jamais dit nous
ne partirons pas nous ne partirons pas
allez nous partirons pas sur un jonction
et nous ne sommes pas partis sur
injonction pas plus l'ambassadeur que
les forces armées françaises
merci merci Madame le Ministre pour le
groupe les républicains notre
vice-président michel Herbillon je vous
remercie beaucoup
mes chers collègues mais madame la
ministre après 9 mois d'un blocus
illégal et inhumain ce que nous
redoutions tous et malheureusement
arrivé la diabète Jean a attaqué les
Arméniens du haut-karabaque le 19
septembre dernier au mépris total du
droit international après avoir provoqué
une grâce une grave crise humanitaire le
président Alif a donc mis en oeuvre sa
promesse de je cite chasser comme des
chiens les Arméniens du haut-karabak en
opérant un véritable nettoyage ethnique
laserbaïdjan des racines ces Arméniens
qui ne demandait qu'à vivre en paix sur
cette terre qu'ils occupent depuis plus
de 2500
ce sont désormais plus de 100 000
réfugiés qui sont arrivés en Arménie au
terme d'un voyage sans retour laissant
toute leur histoire leur culture leur
patrimoine derrière eux et ouvrant ainsi
une insupportable nouvelle crise
humanitaire je veux évidemment au nom
des députés les républicains adresser
notre soutien le plus total à l'Arménie
et aux Arméniens une nouvelle fois
persécutée derrière cet exode forcée se
dissimule le spectre de la poursuite des
attaques de l'Azerbaïdjan contre
l'Arménie et la mise en oeuvre du projet
en turquiste madame la ministre ne leur
n'est plus à la condamnation et à
l'attentisme mais à l'action et vous
avez bien fait de vous déplacer en
Arménie hier et je vous remercie de nous
avoir rendu compte des décisions que
vous avez prises
oui la France doit amplifier son aide
humanitaire et soutenir l'Arménie dans
sa politique d'accueil des habitants du
haut-karabat oui la France doit se
mobiliser plus fermement pour défendre
la souveraineté territoriale de
l'Arménie aujourd'hui présente naï en
prenant des initiatives diplomatiques
fortes pour sensibiliser la communauté
internationale et des concrètement
l'Arménie à se défendre si cette
souveraineté était menacée madame la
ministre que veut dire dans le légal
langage diplomatique que vous avez vous
avez utilisé et que je comprends que
veut dire les actions robustes qui
seraient celle de la France
quelle chance donnez-vous à une
résolution du Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU qui éviterait tout véto vis-à-vis
de l'Union européenne est-ce que la
France va agir pour imposer des
sanctions à l'Azerbaïdjan et dénoncer le
Funès contrat gasier qui l'a dit origine
de Bakou madame la ministre pouvez-vous
nous exposer l'ensemble des initiatives
que la France va prendre sur le plan
diplomatique et sur le plan militaire
pour se prémunir des risques
considérables qui pèsent sur l'Arménie
pays amis de la France menace qui pèse
sur son intégrité territoriale et sur sa
souveraineté merci merci chers collègues
Madame le Ministre
merci
il faut que vous éteignez votre micro
monsieur le député Herbillon votre
question est à double entrée si je puis
dire puisque vous évoquez à la fois la
situation au Caraba et la situation en
Arménie dans le cas du haut-karaba et
j'en ai parlé dans mon introduction il
s'agit évidemment de crime grave quand
tu es de commis d'une violation
flagrante du droit d'être violation
flagrante des droits des populations
arméniennes du yoga de vivre dans le
respect de leur histoire vous l'avez
rappelé qu'elle est longue dans le
respect de leur
identité de leur culture il sera
important de
soutenir la vision selon laquelle
les Arméniens du yoga ont le droit de
retourner sur leur terre s'il le
souhaite et c'est l'objet de nos efforts
une naissance Unis notamment il n'y a
pas attentiste je crois que nous avons
répondu non seulement sur le plan
humanitaire même si nous l'avons fait
sur le plan humanitaire évidemment parmi
les premiers mais pas les seuls et aussi
par une action diplomatique qui ne date
pas d'hier et de ma visite je m'étais
déjà rendue en Arménie
avec
à cette occasion nombre d'échanges sur
la situation dans l'eau Caraba mais cela
fait plus d'un an que nous agissons à
différents niveaux pour peut-être trop
seul je le redis comme je l'ai dit
l'autre jour mobiliser plus fermement la
communauté internationale sur des
nécessité de faire respecter le droit et
les engagements aussi qui sont
rappelons-le ceux de l'Azerbaïdjan dans
le cadre de ses responsabilités
internationales
sur son territoire et en particulier
dans le cadre de l'application de
l'accord de cessez-le-feu de 2020 ça n'a
pas été le cas donc c'est une violation
également des engagements pris à
l'endroit des populations qui vivaient
au Karaba
des engagements qui invitent été pris
par ce pays pour ce qui concerne
l'Arménie
le printemps de la République a utilisé
le mot de vigilance
je l'ai repris
le ministre des armées a sorti
ce rappel de notre extrême vigilance du
rappel de la décision qui est depuis
quelques années celle de la France
d'avoir une coopération en matière de
défense et de sécurité avec ce pays amis
qui est l'Arménie et en particulier avec
la possibilité dont le prolongement des
actions qui ont déjà été menées dans le
passé de lui permettre de poursuivre
l'acquisition de matériel de défense qui
assureait si cela était nécessaire
sa protection de façon encore plus
grande qu'aujourd'hui je parle trop
longtemps pardon madame la Présidente je
voudrais rappeler que sur ces deux
volets notre action se situe à tous les
niveaux possibles au sein d'Union
Européenne je disais ce que nous avons
fait et j'ai profité aussi de mes
conversations lundi avec l'ensemble de
mes partenaires pour les mobiliser
davantage sur le cas de l'Arménie comme
sur le cardio Karaba audience
et je maintiens l'espoir qu'une
résolution puisse
progresser si nous arrivons à créer les
conditions pour cela et j'ajoute même
que auprès de nos différents partenaires
nous saisissons toute occasion pour
appeler leur attention sur le cas de
l'Arménie et sur le risque qu'il y
aurait à ne pas être plus unis et plus
ferme lorsque on s'adresse
à l'Azerbaïdjan en particulier j'ai par
exemple saisi l'occasion hier d'une
réunion téléphonique avec les chefs
d'État ou de gouvernement du G7 plus la
Pologne plus la Roumanie plus le
scrotteur général de l'OTAN réunion à
laquelle je représentais sa demande le
président de la République pour appeler
l'attention des participants sur ce qui
s'est passé au Karaba et sur ce qui ne
doit pas se passer en Arménie
merci merci Madame la Ministre
effectivement quelques petites minutes
en plus mais je pense que les questions
sont extrêmement pertinentes et que nous
avons besoin d'éclaircissement sur la
situation la position de la France et ce
qui est en train d'être fait
concrètement dans les derniers jours et
dernières heures en réalité donc je vous
remercie et je passe tout de suite la
parole à mon collègue Bruno Fox pour le
groupe démocrate
madame la Présidente je voulais avant
toute chose dire en admiration pour le
président bourlange qui pour dans sa vie
d'intervention hier sur l'Arménie alors
que vous-même y étiez et sa question
restera pour pour moi des grands moments
de l'histoire de notre Assemblée
nationale pour être en droit de ligne
son discours sur la défense des valeurs
inaliénables de la démocratie je vais
commencer mon intervention en rendant un
vibrant hommage aussi au président
Bazoom président de la République du
Niger qui comme Jean Le bourlange nous a
exhorté à le faire résiste seul avec sa
famille au coup d'État dont il était
victime comme tous les démocrates de son
pays je voudrais aussi comme vous l'avez
fait qu'on a une pensée pour notre
ambassadeur Sylvain était et tout le
personnel diplomatique qui ont vécu des
moments très difficiles dans l'exercice
de leur mission même la ministre la
situation laquelle nous sommes
confrontés et paradoxal à l'origine des
coups d'État au Sahel la France est
impliquée ni de près ni de loin elle n'a
jamais été mise en cause par les
puccistes dans l'exercice de ces coups
d'État et pourtant au la faillite du
gouvernement IBK défaillant chassés par
les militaires alors que la rue
multipliait les manifestations on Niger
il s'agit d'une sorte de règlement de
compte un train nigérien sur fond de
différents financiers et pourtant à
chaque fois nous vivons le même scénario
la France se retrouve très vite en
première ligne comme le pays à abattre
permettant de justifier apostériori la
légitimité des coups d'État alors
comment en étant arrivé là que n'a-t-on
pas vu que n'a-t-on pas fait qu'a-t-on
fait justement pour se retrouver dans
cette position du paratonnerre une
partie de la réponse se situe peut-être
dans la guerre d'informationnelle sur ce
plan n'a-t-on pas trop longtemps
sous-estimé les capacités de
désinformation de nos adversaires et
leur impact sur les opinions publiques
du Sahel aujourd'hui est ton mieux armé
la problématique du Gabon et
diamétralement opposé après un simulacre
d'élection les militaires n'avaient que
deux alternatives soit comme en 2016 il
tirait sur la foule et provoquer un
nouveau bain de sang ou alors déposer le
président Bongo et sa famille qui se
sont accaparés le pouvoir et une partie
substantielle des richesses de pays
depuis des décennies dans la ministre je
me suis rendu la semaine dernière à
Libreville dans les rues de Libreville
le changement est saisissant on sent la
population après 54 ans de confiscation
du pouvoir de la démocratie apaisée elle
parle librement j'ai rencontré le
président Olivier Nguema mais aussi
toute la classe politique les principaux
opposants comme le professeur Odon ça ou
encore Jean Ping la grande majorité des
gabonaises des Gabonais maltraitée
meurtri et soulagée elle souhaite la
réussite de la transition madame la
ministre après avoir condamné le coup
d'État qu'on appelle sur place le coût
de la paix qui a été réalisé sans coup
de feu comment la France voit-elle
l'évolution de la situation au Gabon
comment voit-elle s'en agnement aux
côtés de la population qui souhaite je
l'ai dit une réussite de la transition
merci merci chers collègues alors encore
une fois beaucoup de questions et
toujours cette question de l'information
nous nous réjouissons d'ailleurs de vous
entendre très prochainement avec notre
collègue Michel Tabarro sur la question
de la relation entre la France et
l'Afrique mais je laisse la ministre
vous répondre
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le député Fuchs nous nous
rejoindrons aisément dans l'hommage que
vous venez de rendre non seulement au
président bourlange mais aux démocratie
et à leur valeur merci de l'avoir fait
merci également d'avoir salué le travail
de nos diplomates et notamment de
l'ambassadeur été monsieur député nous
sommes pas mais vous l'avez dit je crois
en cause ni à l'origine des différents
coups d'État qui se sont succédés au
Sahel ou qui provoquerait les coups
d'État qui se sont succédés au Sahel
vous l'avez dit mais je veux le redire
et j'ai observé
là aussi ce sont les faits que les
manipulations de l'information que l'on
voit se produire viennent souvent dans
un second temps
et donc de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit des
ressorts classiques du populisme et de
la démagogie là comme ailleurs et a cru
par le recours en effet à la
désinformation et l'utilisation de
moyens de déstabilisation puissamment
aidé par
[Musique]
sans doute j'en ai mis l'hypothèse des
acteurs qui ne
se situent pas dans le pays ne sont pas
eux-mêmes des acteurs africains je pense
que vous me comprenez alors nous avons
pris en compte ce phénomène et nous
avons peut-être c'est vrai dû adapter
nos réponses en
créant certains nombre de dispositifs de
veille et de détection des manipulations
de l'information
la différence entre les pharmacols
Russes ou d'autres nationalités et le
travail que nous faisons c'est que nous
nous parlons envisage découvert et nous
n'allons pas proférer des mensonges
éontés inventer des choses qui
n'existent pas diffuser de fausses
nouvelles ou accusés qui que ce soit
de ce qui n'est pas fait il y a
dans l'expression asymétrique cette
difficulté à se battre avec des armes
qui ne sont pas celles de nos
adversaires adversaire que nous ne
voulons pas rejoindre au nom de la
démocratie et des valeurs que vous
célébriez et que je respecte et serre
tout autant que vous nous rejoindrons
pas ce qui font cela dans leur
comportement que ceux-ci soit clair cela
nous expose mais c'est à notre honneur
je pense de rester ce que nous sommes
merci merci madame la ministre et puis
comme vous le savez la question du
visage découvert notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux façon doute nous occuper
très prochainement je donne tout de
suite la parole pour le groupe
socialiste et apparentés la parole à
notre collègue Alain David merci madame
le Président Madame la Ministre chers
collègues on peut vraisemblablement
considérer que la guerre en Ukraine
marque une nouvelle donne des relations
internationales
dans les trois situations sur lesquelles
nous échangeons aujourd'hui madame la
ministre il convient sans doute de tenir
compte de cette évolution
au Gabon comme au Niger la légalité
politique l'influence occidentale sont
battus en brèche et il semble que les
nouveaux protagonistes étaient
considérablement des complexée
avec les collègues du groupe des députés
socialistes et apparentés nous sommes
très attentifs à l'image de la France
qui sait ce qui ne cesse pas de se
dégrader en Afrique et nous suivons de
très près la transition démocratique
promise au Gabon et les suites de la
crise diplomatique avec le Niger et à ce
propos on avait souvent déclaré à propos
de
notre intervention au Sahel qu'on ne
gagnerait pas simplement contre le
terrorisme avec les armes mais également
et plus sûrement par des aides aux
populations en matière économique
formation de l'emploi la lutte contre la
misère en particulier et le désespoir de
la jeunesse qui quelquefois pour 50 ou
100 euros devenu djihadiste
et dans le Caucase là encore on peut
estimer que le coût de force de
l'Azerbaïdjan
au Caraba prend racine dans le
relativisation du principe
d'intangibilité des frontières issues de
l'éclatement de l'Union soviétique d'une
part et dans l'incapacité russe à
s'interposer à caparer et affaibli par
son offensive contre l'Ukraine d'autre
part nous saluons votre déplacement et
revenait et nous confirmons notre
préoccupation vis-à-vis d'autres
velléités de l'Azerbaïdjan et en
particulier sa volonté d'imposer des
changements de frontières notamment dans
le sud de l'Arménie
pouvez-vous nous préciser vos
déclarations sur d'éventuelles
livraisons d'armes à l'Arménie et en
particulier d'autres aides éventuelles
merci chers collègues madame la ministre
merci Madame la vice-présent monsieur le
député David pas mal de questions en une
d'abord pour ce qui concerne le Gabon
nous agissons
avec les mêmes principes que dans
d'autres situations condamnations des
coups d'État et
nous n'avons pas à nous substituer aux
organisations régionales je rappelais
que l'organisation régionale compétente
qui est assez n'avait pas pris dans le
cas du Gabon de mesure de sanctions
contrairement à ce que l'organisation
régionale compétente dans le cas du
Niger avait je rappelais également que
nous comptons les uns et les autres
c'est la première et nous c'est côté que
la transition
puisse se faire rapidement et en suivant
une feuille de route qui mène à des
élections elles-mêmes rapide
je voudrais contester si vous le
permettez l'une de vos affirmations non
l'image de la France ne se dégrade pas
en Afrique elle est de façon
opportuniste démagogique et populiste
instrumentalisé dans des pays
qui sont trois pays du Sahel qui ont
procédé à des coups d'État et parfois
des doubles coup d'État donc là aussi je
vous appelle à ne pas confondre
l'Afrique avec le Sahel ni
l'instrumentation populiste de
manifestations venant souvent d'ailleurs
avec ce que fait notre pays en Afrique
j'ai rappelé aussi les efforts et non
seulement les efforts mais les progrès
que nous faisons pour former les
jeunesses africaines y compris dans
notre pays avec les résultats que vous
connaissez qui sont une forte
augmentation du nombre d'étudiants que
nous accueillons et en complément des
formations que nous faisons sur place
je crois aussi qu'un pays ne fait autant
que la France se rappelait
l'augmentation de notre République au
développement
il serait peut-être
utile que nous nous pénétrions davantage
de cette réalité que nous ne faisons
aucun pays ne fait autant d'efforts vers
le continent africain que notre pays
très brièvement et sur la mini pour en
venir à votre dernière question
je ne suis pas en mesure d'entrer dans
les détails de ce qui pourrait être fait
avec l'hermine dans ce domaine de la
coopération en matière de défense qui
n'est pas un domaine nouveau que nous
entretenons cette relation déjà depuis
plusieurs années la décision qui a été
prise vive à permettre le prolongement
de la coopération qui existe en ouvrant
la possibilité à l'Arménie d'acquérir un
certain nombre de matériels défensifs
dans le respect des règles habituelles
et je dis bien défensif comme je l'ai
dit hier comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure parce qu'il est important de
préciser que cela a pour seul objectif
de permettre à l'Arménie d'être en
situation de mieux se protéger s'il lui
fallait se protéger hypothèse que nous
combattons par ailleurs mais j'ai
rappelé la vigilance que nous attendons
la part pas seulement de la France mais
de toute la communauté internationale à
cet écart
merci merci madame la ministre nous
aurons sans doute l'occasion de revenir
dans le cadre des débats de notre
commission notamment du prochain projet
de loi de finance sur les questions
d'aide au développement et notamment
d'aide au développement en Afrique je
donne tout de suite la parole pour le
groupe horizon et la parenté à notre
collègue Xavier battu
merci madame la Présidente je suis là
dans le petit coin madame la ministre la
France et l'Union européenne on réagi de
concert à la suite de ce coup d'État au
Niger
l'Union européenne par la voie du haut
représentant de l'Union européenne pour
les Affaires étrangères a annoncé
qu'elle ne reconnaît pas et ne
reconnaîtra pas les autorités issues du
push au Niger par la même l'Union
européenne la rejeté tous prises au
pouvoir par la force au Gabon sur le
Niger plus précisément je voudrais je
voudrais vous demander quelle précision
sur la quelques précisions sur l'action
de la France avec l'Union européenne
dans la cadre de la politique étrangère
et de sécurité commune
il y a un mois l'Union européenne
annonçait des sanctions reflétant celle
imposées par la Cedeao à l'encontre du
Niger comprenant des exemptions sur pour
des motifs humanitaires
pouvez-vous nous dire où en sont les
discussions au sein du conseil sur ce
sujet de même si notre ambassadeur a
quitté le Niger il y a toujours une
délégation de l'Union européenne à
Niamey une audience a été accordée par
le Premier ministre pucciste au chef de
la délégation européenne il y a un peu
plus d'une semaine quel contact gardons
nous avec la délégation comment
pouvons-nous agir avec nos partenaires
européens toujours sur le terrain pour
défendre notre position commune pour la
libération du Président Bazoum et le
rétablissement de l'Orne constitutionnel
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
madame la ministre
merci monsieur le député battu sur
l'action de l'Union européenne
et en particulier sur l'action du Haut
représentant quelque chose à Borel je
veux vous donner personnellement le
témoignage d'un soutien constant que
nous avons trouvé en la personne du Haut
représentant l'Union européenne en tant
que telle a immédiatement et elle aussi
comme tant d'autres condamnés cette
tentative de coup d'État elle a appelé à
la libération de Bazoom elle appelait à
la restauration de l'ordre
constitutionnel et je le disais tout à
l'heure lors de notre dernière réunion
informelle à la fin du mois d'août nous
avons
à l'unanimité décidé la création d'un
cadre de sanction ce travail est en
cours j'espère qu'il sera fini et
devrait l'être courant octobre il est
temps
par ailleurs l'Union européenne a
suspendu sa coopération avec le Niger
comme la plupart des États membres de
l'Union
je remercie aussi
l'ambassadeur représentant l'Union
européenne au Niger d'avoir manifesté
son soutien plusieurs repris directement
auprès de notre ambassadeur d'avoir même
je le rappelais tout à l'heure voulu lui
rendre visite et en avoir été empêché
par les bouts de continuons ce travail
il faut maintenant qu'une décision
définitive surprise sur le cadre de
sanction qui permettra un certain nombre
de désignations nous y travaillons
autant avec l'Union africaine qu'avec la
CEDEAO qui est celle qui doit nous
donner des informations
documentées sur les personnes qui
devraient être l'objet de ces sanctions
dans un deuxième temps
merci merci madame la ministre pour le
groupe écologiste et la parenté notre
collègue Aurélien Tachet merci
récemment exprimé dans une interview que
l'Afrique attend trop de la France la
Mauritanie pays dont j'ai l'honneur
d'assurer la présidence du groupe
d'amitié si elle l'assemblée dont nous
recevons bientôt une délégation
officielle est un îlot de stabilité dans
la région elle a condamné le coup d'État
au Niger tout comme à la condamné tous
les coups d'État précédent dans le Sahel
et elle a eu bien sûr eu raison mais ce
sentiment partagé par le président
razouni n'est pas exemples de questions
précises quand à notre relation avec le
continent et qui trouve un large écho je
vais donc le redire ici car ça a été
largement passé ce silence contrairement
à ce qui a affirmé le président de la
République il y a une dizaine de jours
au journal de 20h le monde dans ces
pages du 19 août dernier nous apprenait
que les forces de sécurité loyales aux
prises dans Bazoom ont tenté de mettre
fin au coup d'État quand elles ont tenté
de mettre fin au coup d'État au Niger
que la France était prête à intervenir
militairement et que ce Mohamed Bazoum
lui-même qui s'est opposé à cette
intervention et heureusement que nous
n'avons pas déclenché un vos conflits au
sel qui n’auraient profité qu'au groupe
terroristes et aggraver la pauvreté
extrême dans cette région madame
ministre un retenu de notre action
catastrophique en Libye ce qu'on appelle
improprement le sentiment anti-français
est ainsi pas simplement alimenté par
des forces ennemies je pense bien sûr au
Miss Wagner ou à l'etarus lui-même ses
forces existent à jouer un rôle très
néfaste mais il y a aussi un aujourd'hui
un rejet de notre politique africaine et
ce n'est pas être défaitiste que de dire
ça c'est simplement refuser le déni
madame la ministre vous avez décidé de
geler les visas des ressortissants
maliens au burkinabè juste après que les
régimes de Bamako et de ouagadougoué
reconnu le pulsion mais pourquoi punir
ainsi les peuples en raison de désaccord
politique avec le dirigeant nous faisons
ici le jeu des pushistes et des forces
étrangères qui les soutiennent qu'en
est-il aussi de l'aide of development en
direction de ces nations vous avez dit
que les projets humanitaires pourraient
continuer mais par exemple les projets
d'expertise France comme celui que cette
organisme mène actuellement au Burkina
Faso contre le palu va-t-il pouvoir se
poursuivre mon collègue car une bencher
ici présent vous a interpellé à
plusieurs reprises à ce sujet par
courrier sans réponse pour le moment une
autre question cruciale demeure madame
ministre où iront nos militaires
actuellement stationnés au Niger la
Mauritanie préside le G5 Sahel vient de
dire qu'elle n'accueillerait pas ses
forces sur son sol alors qu'elle sera
leur prochain poste le tchat nous
continuons de soutenir la jungle didriss
Déby le Gabon vous avez validé une
révolution de palette car favorable à
notre pays ce récit ainsi poursuivre
dans la politique africaine en échec et
ma conviction et que la plupart de nos
troupes est bases militaires est
présente en Afrique aujourd'hui ne sont
plus souhaités et doivent donc être
fermés qu'en pensez-vous madame la
ministre merci cher collègue pour cette
question vraiment très vaste qui va de
la Libye à la Mauritanie en passant par
les ressortissants maliens et burkinabè
la ministre je vous laisse les tâches de
répondre en deux minutes 30
merci merci Madame la visseuse merci
monsieur le député tâché les propos du
président mauritanien sont intéressants
et pourraient peut-être inspirer
quelques
réflexions l'une d'entre elles et qu'il
est le premier à qualifier le le
discours anti français de populisme
comme je l'ai fait moi-même et comme je
vous engage à le considérer et donc nous
devenons nous deviendrions responsables
de tous ce n'est pas le confortement de
la France ce n'est pas elle qui fait des
faits les régimes la politique des pays
africains ce n'est pas non plus elle qui
fait les coups d'État je veux le redire
après l'avoir dit ailleurs
un mot sur un article de presse que vous
avez évoqué j'étais au côté du président
de la République le 26 juillet et les
jours suivants et je peux vous dire en
quelques mots que contrairement à
ce qui a été écrit je vais le tour de
trop la quasi-totalité de ce qui a été
écrit dans cet article est inexact voilà
je me préciserai pas ce qu'il était ce
qui n'était pas mais je pense que vous
me comprenez
il n'y a aucune
décision de notre part je le redis de ne
plus accueillir d'artistes ou
d'étudiants de ces trois pays
que ce soit clair je l'ai dit dans
l'hémicycle je vous le redis nous avons
suspendu la coopération en dehors de
l'humanitaire
dans ces pays avec ce pays et pour une
notion qui est que non nous ne voulons
pas nous ne devons pas mener des actions
de coopération et financer des régimes
Pucci dont une partie se sert de ce qui
leur vient de certains de leurs
partenaires ou des institutions
financières internationales pour aider
d'autres bougies à mener d'autres coups
d'État comme le Mali et soupçonné de
l'avoir fait avec le Niger et
les visages je voulais dire reprendront
dès que d'ailleurs certains sont donnés
et reprendront dès que nous avons
parachever le recalage des formats dans
des pays où nos consulats et en période
sont exposés elles l'ont été au Burkina
objet d'attaque elles ont été au Niger
objet d'attaque donc la coopération je
le redis si elle baisse elle baisse du
fait des bouts de schistes par de la
nôtre
je crois avoir répondu pratiquement
toutes vos questions si j'en oublie
écoutez c'est une question à voir avec
le ministère des armées je n'ai pas
entendu que le Président de la
République est dit autre chose que le
fait qu'elle se retirerait en bon ordre
et d'ici la fin de l'année
merci Madame la Ministre
enfin pour la dernière prise de parole
le nom d'un groupe pour la Gauche
démocrate et républicaine notre
vice-président Jean-Paul Lecoq merci
madame la Présidente moi je sais pas si
j'ai des questions à vous poser madame
la ministre parce que en deux minutes 30
essayez de faire l'antithèse de ce que
vous avez aimé plusieurs dizaines de
minutes à exposer c'est quasiment
œuvre impossible et donc
je considère que moi que la France
souffre d'une politique
la géométrie variable en Afrique des
dictateurs que l'on soutient d'autres
que l'on ne soutient pas des des
positionnements à un moment donné que
l'on soutient vous dites la CEDEAO là
CEDEAO c'est quand même un peu la France
par rapport à ceux qu'on a installé mais
si mais si vous voulez pas le
reconnaître mais c'est ce que justement
les peuples africains vous reprochent la
le français enfin un moment donné les
Africains ils ont essayé de créer leur
propre monnaie mais on était intervenus
pour essayer de dire non non on va
continuer et je pourrais multiplier les
exemples mais il me faudrait plus de 2
minutes 30 pour le faire et donc c'est
impossible de vous contredire donc vous
allez me traiter de populiste parce qu'à
un moment donné je m'autorise le fait
mais j'ai eu droit à l'antisémitisme
aussi alors je suis antisémite populiste
et communiste aussi il faudra que vous
l'acceptiez et non non mais c'est ça
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné on a
plus cette possibilité là moi je vais
vous interroger sur sur une autre
situation puisque il est quasiment
impossible de le faire sur les questions
africaines
c'est la question du Maroc
pourquoi est-ce que le roi du Maroc a
refusé l'aide de la France quand on
connaît les les liens qui unissent le
peuple français le peuple marocain et
les liens très proches voire des liens
familiaux qui unissent ces deux poples
ministre si c'est parce que la France a
refusé de reconnaître le Sahara
Occidental marocain je vous félicite et
je vous félicite de ne pas avoir cédé et
je remercie le président de la
République de ne pas avoir cédé depuis
tout à l'heure vous nous expliquer que
le droit international doit être
respecté j'aime quand vous dites ça
j'aimerais encore mieux quand vous
appliquerez ça et le jour où vous
permettrez qu'il y ait un référendum
d'autodétermination comme premier en
1991 au peuple sahraoui pour qu'il
baisse les armes ce qu'il avait fait
mais on lui a pas permis la référendum
le jour où vous obtiendrez cela madame
la ministre je vous dirais que la France
a fait œuvre utile dans un pays africain
et peut-être dans d'autres mais en
attendant je ne pense pas
merci merci chers collègues en tout cas
on peut débattre librement dans cette
commission et tous les tous les avis
s'expriment et la ministre répond à tout
mais on mais en tout cas je laisse
madame la ministre vous répondre sur sur
cette question
je vous ai parlé
merci Madame la vice-président merci
monsieur le député le TOC comme vous
n'avez pas contesté ce que je disais le
coq j'ai dit oui comme vous n'avez pas
contesté ce que je dis je ne contesterai
pas ce que vous n'avez pas dit vous avez
dit néanmoins une chose dont je vous
laisse la paternité je reviendrai sur le
mot
la Cedeo c'est la France
voilà du paternalisme je crois qu'on
n'avez pas tourné la page peut-être de
la France Afrique que je suis sûr vous
dénoncer par ailleurs
le Maroc faut-il le redire le Maroc n'a
refusé aucune aide ni l'aide de la
France ni l'aide des États-Unis ni
l'aide de l'Allemagne il aide de
l'Italie le Maroc a décidé
souverainement d'organiser des secours
comme il l'entendait l'a fait de façon
efficace d'ailleurs il faut le dire et
avec je le redis après l'avoir dit sur
le moment puisque j'étais souvent
interrogée sur ce point des contacts à
tous niveaux entre nous-mêmes et les
autorités marocaines pour définir ceux
qui étaient leurs besoins lesquels
dépassent la phase d'urgence et nous en
parlons avec nos homologues marocains
les uns et les autres
sur le front
CFA là aussi on ranime des débats
[Musique]
qui sont des débats qui ont été menés
dans le passé et qui oublient de
rappeler peut-être l'essentiel les pays
se déterminent librement et l'objectif
du franc CFA lorsque des pays adhèrent
au système CFA et de garantir la
solidité et la convertibilité de leur
monnaie ça me semble des avantages
autant que ça leur a semblé
à eux qui ont reste les partisans
il y avait il y avait
une autre question à la fin de votre
intervention je ne sais plus très bien à
quel
le saint occidental non c'est pas
dommage parce que ça permet de rappeler
la position constante de la France sur
ce sujet constante parce qu'en effet
elle n'a pas varié au soutien des
Nations Unies des efforts des Nations
Unies et du Représentant spécial du
Secrétaire général des Nations unies sur
ce dossier comme sur d'autres je crois
que nous sommes cohérents
merci merci Madame le Ministre les
prises de parole pour les groupes ayant
été achevés nous passons maintenant aux
questions individuelles et je donne tout
de suite la parole à mon collègue Didier
pour le groupe Renaissance enfin merci
Madame la Ministre Catherine Colonna la
France est au rendez-vous de l'Histoire
hier de yélan vous avez annoncé des
mesures fortes à l'égard de l'Arménie
pour l'accord de livraison de matériel
militaire de défense merci pour l'appel
à l'attribution de la facilité
européenne pour la paix à l'Arménie
merci pour la demande d'élargissement de
la mission de l'Europe en Arménie merci
maintenant il faut convaincre nos
partenaires et créer les conditions d'un
véritable élan européen de solidarité à
l'égard de l'Arménie parce que le régime
de Bakou est dangereux madame la
ministre et que le haut carabar ne
pourrait être que le début
est-il possible de geler les avoir du
clan alien et de renvoyer son ambassade
Driss de France
quelle est la marge de manoeuvre de la
France sur la libération des prisonniers
politiques arrêtées en arts je pense à
Rouben vardagnan ancien ministre je
pense à Reik à routinho ancien président
ou alors à Baco ça qui ont et bien
d'autres et enfin sur le plan
humanitaire pourrait-on avec l'Union
européenne comme le disait hier avec
brio le président bourlange déployé un
véritable plan Marshall pour revenir en
aide à ces populations chassées et
assassinées merci chers collègues madame
la ministre
voilà mais merci beaucoup monsieur le
député par hacker merci du salut que
vous avez fait à quelques-unes des
décisions de la France je vous en suis
reconnaissante nous serons d'accord sur
le fait qu'il faut continuer de
convaincre et sa raison pour laquelle je
plaise régulièrement près l'Union
européenne et dans les contacts directs
et dans les démarches officielles que
j'ai pu entreprendre pour ce qui
concerne la facilité européenne de paix
comme pour la mission européenne
d'observation il faut convaincre et
j'observe que l'Allemagne bouge par
exemple qu'un certain angle de nos
partenaires qui étaient peut-être moins
attentifs au sort de l'Arménie au sort
des Arméniens que nous le sommes
ouvrent les yeux progressivement les
pays de d'Europe centrale et orientale
aussi comprennent mieux désormais que la
Russie n'est plus la Russie qui protège
l'Arménie et les Arméniens
mais la Russie qui a été complice de le
complice de l'opération militaire menée
par l'Azerbaïdjan nous poursuivons nos
efforts bien sûr et la première mise
sera répandue à l'interpellation du
président Bourlon hier en indiquant que
nous travaillons à plan de soutien
européen faudra aller au-delà des
Européens d'ailleurs je pense pour aider
encore davantage l'Arménie enfin sur la
question des prisonniers que vous avez
évoquées j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer au Conseil de sécurité dans
cette réunion que nous avions pu obtenir
en urgence et qui s'était tenu du mardi
je crois au jeudi j'ai rappelé la
position de la France à cet égard nous
demandons que les prisonniers lorsqu'ils
ont respecté l'accord de cesser le feu
non pas pris les armes et ne se sont pas
livrés des actions qui par ailleurs se
reconstitutives
de fait répréhensible nous demandons
qu'il soit relâché je l'ai dit
officiellement au nom de la France au
Conseil de sécurité mais il est bon de
le rappeler
merci Madame la Ministre maintenant le
député LFI Sébastien delogu la parole
est à vous merci beaucoup madame la
ministre je vais commencer directement
par les questions moi je voudrais savoir
que comptez-vous faire pour ceux qui
s'apparentent de crime de guerre
flagrant combien d'Azerbaïdjan pour
qu'il ne reste pas impuni je voudrais
savoir aussi que va faire la France pour
empêcher les autres pays d'alimenter
cette guerre parce que
je sais que la France c'est le pays qui
fait le plus pour l'Arménie c'est très
bien merci beaucoup mais en parallèle la
présidente de l'Union européenne vendeur
lionne est invité à votre lancement de
campagne européenne alors qu'elle signe
des traités avec le pays azéri sur par
exemple l'accord gasier européen qui met
justement en péril le peuple arménien et
moi aussi je reviens d'Arménie il y a
quelques heures je vous avais d'ailleurs
demandé de vous de vous accompagner je
suis allé à la frontière à Goris j'ai vu
les réfugiés il y avait un balai
incessant de camions transportant des
réfugiés il y avait des ambulances des
voitures chargées à ras bord de famille
fuyant leur terre leur maison des
visages étaient froids fermés résignés
et les gens pleurer
et ils m'ont prouvé par des vidéos et
des photos les crimes de guerre de
torture de châtiment corporels
d'amputation etc etc et vous ne pouvez
pas avoir un double jeu en invitant la
présidente de l'Union européenne à votre
lancement de campagne et derrière dire
que vous soutenez le peuple arménien
merci beaucoup pardonnez-moi pour le
moment merci cher collègue madame la
ministre
voilà pardon merci monsieur le député de
l'augus je regrette que vous n'ayez pas
pu m'accompagner j'ignorais que vous en
aviez mis le souhait mais au demeurant
vous savez que ça n'aurait pas été je
pense matériellement possible dans la
mesure où je suis venu de Kiev en
passant par la Pologne et elle est
directement là-bas nous avons qualifié
de crimes et même le crime grave les
actions menées par l'Azerbaïdjan à
l'encontre de la population arménienne
duo Karaba et j'ai aussi salué hier
puisque la décision était prise par le
Parlement arménien hier le fait que
l'Arménie va bientôt devenir État partie
au Statut de Rome c'est-à-dire rejoindre
le groupe des États qui font agir la
Cour pénale internationale dans les
domaines où elle est compétente et la
compétence de la Cour est large et elle
permet aussi vous le savez de remonter
jusqu'aux responsable d'une action
sur le gaz nous nous en parlons souvent
il ne faut pas faire de lien entre
les relations qui peuvent exister et qui
existent entre l'Union européenne et
l'Azerbaïdjan dans ce domaine et la
position des États membres de l'Union
européenne
regardant le haut Karaba regardant le
droit des populations aminées du haut
karma et regardant l'Arménie eau
demeurant vous le savez sans doute
monsieur le député puisque vous vous
intéressez à la question
l'Azerbaïdjan n'est pas un fournisseur à
titre principal de l'Union européenne
d'autre part le doublement des
livraisons dont il est question donc de
quantité encore une fois qui sont en
pourcentage relativement modeste n'est
pas encore intervenu or c'est
aujourd'hui qu'interviennent les
opérations militaires de la cerbaïdjan
contre la population arménienne préparer
de longue date et j'ai eu l'occasion
tout à l'heure de rappeler parce qu'il
le faut encore et encore que notre pays
n'a pas attendu hier pour s'intéresser à
cette question il a de longues dates été
aux côtés de l'Arménie était aux côtés
des Arméniens je regrette qu'il faille
que les événements récents ouvrent les
yeux dans certains nombres de nos
partenaires et bien sûr faut-il le dire
monsieur le député je ressens la même
émotion que vous devant les atrocités
qui ont été commises j'étais aux côtés
de grand brûlés
venant du caramel hier et je ne cache
pas mon émotion
merci merci madame la ministre et merci
pour ce pour ce témoignage je passe tout
de suite la parole à notre collègue le
président anglais
merci merci beaucoup madame la
présidente madame la ministre moi je
tiens aussi à saluer le soutien que vous
avez témoigné au peuple arménien à
travers votre déplacement d'hier et la
volonté de la France de soutenir la
facilité européenne de paix je crois que
c'est important il faut désormais comme
la souligner collègues Didier PARAKIAN
juste précédemment entraîné nos
partenaires européens de manière à bâtir
une verrière véritable appui européen
pour une Arménie indépendante souveraine
et démocratique je crois que c'est
extrêmement important je voudrais
brièvement vous interroger sur votre
déplacement à Kiev pour sortir du débat
africain et arménien qui nous anime vous
étiez à Kiev avant-hier pour une réunion
des 27 ministre étrangères une réunion
unique c'est une première et je crois
que c'était un symbole extrêmement fort
à un moment donné où la Russie compte
sur une forme de lassitude des Européens
dans face à la guerre qu'elles mène
depuis maintenant plus d'un an et demi
et j'aurais aimé savoir les actions que
vous avez décider avec vos partenaires
européens pour soutenir l'Ukraine dans
la durée l'aider aussi à préparer
l'hiver parce que nous savons que la
Russie va se servir de ces mois d'hiver
pour attaquer à nouveau les
infrastructures civiles et énergétiques
et donc j'aurais aimé vous entendre plus
en détail sur sur ces points merci
beaucoup
merci cher collègue et merci de nous
permettre de parler aussi de ce sujet
vous savez que cette commission est très
attentive la situation en Ukraine et
peut-être grâce à cette question pour
nous l'aborder très brièvement même la
ministre merci monsieur le député
anglais de monsieur le Président Anglade
en effet nous n'avions pas parlé alors
que c'est un sujet important de
l'actualité internationale et pour notre
sécurité collective aussi évidemment
vous avez raison la réunion d'hier était
tout à fait exceptionnelle c'était un
signe important pour adresser un message
de solidarité à l'Ukraine en tant que
européen de solidarité et d'unité et
c'est d'ailleurs pour tout vous dire la
raison pour laquelle j'avais suggéré ce
conseil à faire étrangères informel à
Joseph Borel et à des microcoliba avant
l'été et nous avons pu avancer et même
tenir ce qui avait été envisagé j'en
étais particulièrement heureuse hier le
principal message c'est celui que vous
avez rappelé nous sommes unis et aux
côtés de l'UK réunit dans la durée je
l'ai dit que la Russie ne compte pas sur
notre lassitude nous nous laisserons pas
et donc nous sommes ni pour
l'accompagner dans cette ce combat qui
est le sien pour sa souveraineté son
indépendance en intégrité territoriale
unis pour mettre en échec l'agression
russe et unit aussi pour l'accompagner à
terme sur ce chemin qui l'amènera vers
l'Union européenne dans les principaux
sujets de nos échanges mais c'était un
conseil informel donc sans décision
formelle nous avons évoqué
principalement le soutien militaire dans
la suite du sommet de l'OTAN de Vigneux
c'est avec la volonté de renforcer
dans une perspective de quelques années
l'appui que nous apportons à l'Ukraine
notamment en renforçant les possibilités
de production vous avez vu la visite de
Sébastien Lecornu et tout ce qui a pu
être fait à ce titre
poursuivre mais les actions avaient déjà
été décédées au mois de de juin lors de
la rue conférence sur la reconstruction
de l'Ukraine qui s'était tenu à Londres
les moyens d'aider l'Ukraine à faire
face à l'hiver et faire face sans doute
à la reprise par la Russie des
bombardements sur les infrastructures
civiles énergétiques
ukrainienne j'ai pu me rendre j'allais
dire hier trop de nuit sans sommeil
avant-hier lundi dans une centrale
électrique qui est l'une des
sous-stations des deux principales
qualimentaires pour regarder avec eux ce
que nous faisons ensemble
l'autre thème a été bien sûr les
réformes en vue du du cheminement vers
l'Union européenne avec un rapport de
progrès de la Commission européenne qui
est attendue dans les tous premiers
jours du mois de novembre et une
décision qui devrait être prise par le
Conseil européen de décembre nous avons
aussi
travaillé sur le plan de paix
ukrainien et la façon de le décliner sur
chacun des différents
thèmes en processus plus opérationnel à
même de regrouper davantage notamment de
la communauté internationale comme ça
c'est fait à Copenhague comme ça c'est
fait à Jeddah et comme il faut continuer
de le faire auprès de pays qui sont
moins prêts de l'Ukraine que nous voilà
un mot pour conclure pour dire que cette
réunion manifeste notre volonté de
rester aux côtés de l'Ukraine
durablement à notre détermination
ressentir que la Russie ne compte pas
sur une érosion de cette détermination
merci madame la ministre je pense que
c'est un message très important et le
fait de savoir aussi avoir ce compte
rendu de votre part nous donner
évidemment envie d'en savoir davantage
et il y aura probablement d'autres
auditions dédiées à l'Ukraine je passe
toute la parole à notre collègue père
Henri du monde député du Pas-de-Calais
pour une question
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
revenir madame le ministre sur les
relations entre la France et le Maroc
terrible drame qui a frappé le royaume
le mois dernier a malheureusement mis en
lumière les dissensions extrêmement
profondes des liens jadis solide et
amicaux entre nos deux pays article de
presse proposé maladresse diplomatique
et politique courbette à l'Algérie nous
reconnaissances de la maroqueté du
Sahara absence de nomination d'un
ambassadeur du Royaume du Maroc en
France non réception des lettres de
créance de notre ambassadeur par le roi
du Maroc il y a quelques jours jamais le
fossé entre les deux rives de la
Méditerranée n'a été aussi profond ma
question est donc simple quel est le
plan d'un diplomatie française quel est
votre plan pour aplanir les relations
entre nos deux pays et mettre fin à
cette crise sans précédent pas très loin
de la rupture diplomatique je vous
remercie
question simple mais réponse sans doute
complexes madame la ministre merci
Madame la vision merci monsieur le
député Dumont je crois que vous voyez la
réalité comme ce qu'elle n'est pas d'une
façon particulièrement noire en ne
retenant que les éléments qui vient de
rayer la pite de votre thèse il n'y a
pas de crise entre la France et le Maroc
nous entretenons avec ce pays un
partenariat qu'on qualifie de
partenariats d'exception au service des
intérêts partagés de nos pays si vous
évoquez le fait que la cérémonie de
remise des lettres de créance qui
concernait entre autres notre
ambassadeur et des reportés il y a
quelques jours par le palais je dois
vous rappeler que ça concerne les
quelques 30 ambassadeurs ou peut-être
davantage qui n'ont pas encore pu
remettre leur lettre de créance à Sa
Majesté le Roi du Maroc parmi ces 30
ambassadeur qui attend depuis je crois
des mois si ce n'est une grosse année
figurait notre ambassadeur je vous
demande de vérifier ce point car je suis
certaine de ce que je vous dis
voilà sur le Maroc ce que je peux vous
répondre en quelques mots merci nous
aurons peut-être aussi l'occasion d'y
revenir l'idée après le bureau de la
commission a quand même acté le fait de
faire davantage de réunions thématiques
et de table ronde donc nous sommes tous
très intéressés
maintenant pour pour la majorité notre
collègue Renaissance Liliana Tanguy
c'est à vous
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre en tant que membre du groupe
d'amitié parlementaire France Arménie je
voulais également saluer les initiatives
de la France
et son soutien constant à l'Arménie que
vous avez marqué hier par votre visite
votre déplacement Erevan et j'aurai
moi-même l'occasion de souligner notre
soutien
lors de la prochaine session de
l'Assemblée parlementaire du Conseil de
l'Europe qui va organiser un débat
d'urgence sur la situation au Karaba
mais je voulais également évoquer la
question de du Niger vous avez rappelé
que que le rôle clé que jouait nos
forces militaires dans la lutte
antiterroriste
et avec le retrait de nos forces armées
je voulais savoir selon vous comment la
France va-t-elle pouvoir poursuivre sa
mission
de lutte contre les groupes djihadistes
qui donc ont considérablement
accrue leurs attaques vous l'avez
rappelé et la nouvelle stratégie Afrique
France qui avait été annoncé par le
président de la République en février
dernier
va-t-elle pas être remise en cause dans
cette région et vous avez parlé aussi
des sanctions européennes
à l'égard du Niger pour faire plier la
jante est-ce que vous pensez qu'on
devrait davantage coopérer en européen
en Afrique pour justement maintenir la
stabilité dans cette région
merci j'espère que la merci beaucoup
madame la ministre
merci madame la députée Tanguy la lutte
contre les groupes armées terroristes ne
se suivra pas de la même façon après la
fin de l'opération Berkane au Mali après
le double coup d'État qui a eu lieu au
Burkina Faso et après le coup d'État qui
est en cours au Niger et je redis que
nous n'avons aucune attention
de mener une coopération militaire avec
des bouts de schistes
il faudra donc mais je le disais tout à
l'heure d'un mot revoir les formes de
coopération avec nos partenaires
intéressés européens et au-delà je citer
je crois les États-Unis d'Amérique et
vous savez le rôle qu'ils ont au Niger
et
revoir aussi la contribution qui peut
être la nôtre dans le cadre de la
nouvelle politique
décidé par le Président de la République
et rendu public d'abord au mois de
novembre puis à nouveau spécifiquement
novembre 2022 puis le nouveau
spécifiquement tout récemment à la fin
du mois de février qui consiste à
mettre moins de présence de force
militaires françaises sur le terrain de
façon à augmenter du proportion si je
puis dire les activités de formation
ainsi que la fourniture de matériel et
d'équipements pour mieux répondre aux
besoins de nos partenaires une
diminution des effectifs qui est en
cours qui a été annoncée qui est public
et qui a été bien sûr menée en
concertation avec chacun des pays
concernés pour les différentes étapes
qui seront celles de cette
réarticulation
dans dans ce cadre nous continuerons
d'appuyer les pays qui nous le
demanderait dans des formes à déterminer
mais je ne vous cache pas que d'une
façon générale bien sûr la lutte contre
le terrorisme est affecté par ses
codétat militaires la réalité sur le
terrain d'ailleurs le montre mais nous
ne pouvons pas imaginer de mener des
coopérations avec des puces qui font du
mal à leur pays alors population autre
qu'ils portent atteindre au processus
démocratique que nous soutenons
merci Madame la Ministre maintenant pour
la France insoumise notre collègue
Nadège à beaumont-goli merci Madame
présidente mes chers collègues madame la
ministre il y a quelques jours certains
élus communistes de Paris ont demandé à
ce que les biens immobiliers supposés
mal acquis de la famille Bongo soit
récupérer par l'État et puis céder à la
ville de Paris pour en faire des
logements sociaux pour les Parisiens
c'est une exigence qui nous a semblé
surprenante car ce qui est supposé avoir
été pris au gabonais doit revenir au
gabonais à l'issue de procédures
judiciaires transparente dans le cas
contraire ça ça peut rentrer à une
énième spoliation du peuple gabonais
avec la complicité de la France et ceci
alors que notre pays a déjà par le passé
était accusé d'avoir été laxiste voir
complice face à des investissements
immobiliers douteux de chefs d'État
étrangers sur son sol sans surprise les
autorités de gabonaises ont dénoncé
cette initiative je tiens d'ailleurs à
saluer la réactivité de l'ambassade de
France à Libreville qui a rapidement
rappelé l'existence du dispositif bien
mal acquis votez il y a deux ans par
notre assemblée dans le cadre de ce
mécanisme toutes les Sabres récoltés
doivent être fléchés au plus près des
populations concernées madame la
ministre pouvez-vous nous dire où nous
en sommes sur la question des biens mal
acquis quel contact avec les autorités
de fait au Gabon et par ailleurs le
mécanisme apparemment a été
enclenché concernant la Guinée
équatoriale de ce point de vue là
pouvez-vous nous dire où en est-on
également merci cher collègue madame la
ministre
merci madame la députée
vous savez que le dispositif vous le
rappeliez de la loi de 2021 sur les
biens manaquis permet de créer un
mécanisme qui au bout d'une procédure
judiciaire permet de restituer aux
populations les recettes de la vente des
biens saisis une fois que la justice
était rendue de façon définitive et ceci
à travers des projets précis des projets
immunitaires des projets de
développement je vais observer qu'on a
cet égard un dispositif qui est unique
au monde et donc
je ne comprends pas comment vous en
venez à parler de complicité quand notre
pays exemplaire à cet égard pour ce qui
concerne le Gabon à ma connaissance il
n'y a aucune décision de justice à ce
jour
concernant les membres de la famille de
l'ancien président
qui sont mis en examen et donc les
procédures
judiciaires sont en cours elles sont en
cours je ne peux pas les commenter sur
la Guinée équatoriale
en revanche si je suis bien informé la
justice s'est prononcé c'est prononcé de
façon définitive par un arrêt du 10
février
confirmé par l'accord de cassation le 28
juillet 2021 les biens confisqués sont
donc la propriété désormais de l'État
français et les autorités françaises
travaillent l'exécution de cette
décision notamment dans le cadre du
mécanisme de restitution de la loi de
1921 c'est donc un travail
2021 j'ai bien dit 2021
1900 la fatigue fait son non œuvre
marche arrière nous nous sommes donc
dans le cadre de l'application de ce
mécanisme madame la députée merci madame
la ministre
toujours toujours pour toujours pour la
France insoumise notre collègue Carlos
bilongo
merci madame la présidente madame
ministre chers collègues moi je
reviendrai sur sur l'Arménie on a une
question d'une seule députée
de l'augus et Monsieur le Député David
mais j'aimerais des précisions la France
a donné son accord pour délivraisons
matériels militaire mais de quel type la
nature des équipements j'aimerais savoir
et ensuite plus généralement quels
seront les actions réelles donc la
nation de l'offensive de Azerbaïdjan on
ne peut que se demander si la France et
l'Europe
ne font pas peser sur la balance
l'intérêt pétrolier et gazier liés à les
aberjans vous avez plus ou moins répondu
à mon collègue mais je suis obligé de
revenir parce que ça fait des semaines
et des mois que la communauté arménienne
qui vient en France nous interpelle vers
des plaidoyer sur des mails des
rassemblements des manifestations sur
cette situation d'urgence et vous avez
été sur place je salue vous déplacement
et vous avez fait un retour sur les
situations très adamantes et les
nettoyage ethnique a été réaliser
dans le Karaba voilà je vous remercie
pour vos réponses merci merci Madame la
Ministre effectivement ça a été déjà
merci monsieur le député bilongo merci
Madame la vice-présente la France a
donné son accord et dans le prolongement
des relations qui existent déjà entre
elles et l'Arménie pour que un travail
soit fait sur la possibilité pour
l'Arménie d'acquérir du matériel de
défense auprès de la France voilà une
décision de principe qui demeure
maintenant une décision qui va falloir
mettre en oeuvre c'est donc tout
simplement
une décision d'exportation de matériel
militaire classique et qui relève
classiquement du secret de la défense
nationale j'ai
souhaité je vous le redis préciser qu'il
s'agit là de matériel défensif pour que
les choses soient clairement entendues
je crois avoir répondu sur
le contrat gazier et je dois ajouter que
si un pays qui n'est pas dépendant du
gaz nius
c'est bien la France vous aviez enfin
une dernière question
[Musique]
pardonnez-moi
du dernier élément de votre question la
condamnation des actions de
l'Azerbaïdjan nous y procédons nous
procédons pas seul je vous ai dit aussi
des efforts que nous menons aux Nations
unies pour voir si il est possible et
dans quelles conditions il est possible
de faire progresser une résolution qui
aurait non seulement cet objectif car
cela ferait partie de nos objectifs mais
l'objectif de rappeler les droits
historiques des populations arméniennes
du Karaba a retourné si elle le souhaite
sur leur terre et dans le respect de
leurs droits il y a eu en complément
un rappel par le Président de la
République de notre vigilance vous êtes
libre de le traduire par une mise en
garde même si le mot n'a pas été employé
mais
j'ai fait ce rappel également hier parce
qu'il ne doit pas y avoir de doute sur
le fait que nous aurions des réactions
si
l'intégrité territoriale de l'harmonie
devait venir être mise en cause et c'est
une question qui est largement partagée
que nous nous employons faire partager
par un plus grand groupe de pays encore
que nous voulons rassembler
merci Madame la Ministre de la qui est
très très clair je donne tout de suite
la parole à notre collègue Karim benchek
qui nous rejoint exceptionnellement pour
cette séance
merci Madame la vice-présidente madame
la ministre
sans rien nier au à la campagne de déo
campagne de désinformation et à
l'opportunité de certains acteurs bien
connus que vous avez citées
sans nier la brutalisation sans
précédent des relations internationales
pensez-vous que le démantèlement subi
par notre réseau diplomatique
particulièrement au sel au cours des 15
dernières années et eu des conséquences
pensez-vous que le fait que nous n'ayons
jamais atteint les objectifs de Sicile
de concentration de l'aide sur les 19
pays les plus vulnérables dont font
notamment partie les pays du Sahel et eu
des conséquences vous disiez tout à
l'heure que nous avions atteint une APD
jamais atteinte au précédemment oui nous
sommes le 4e bailleur mais il faut il
faut s'en féliciter c'est très bien mais
faut aussi dire que notre aide est très
particulière vu qu'elle ne repose plus
sur du prêt quasi exclusivement sur du
prêt sur les dix années qui ont dont on
parle si et
il est toujours très difficile de prêter
à des pays non éligibles auprès au final
pensez-vous que les choix budgétaires
fait tout au long des 15 dernières
années et jouer un rôle sans faire
l'autoflagellation mais juste pour avoir
un regard aussi lucide sur ce qui s'est
passé et jouer un rôle dans les
déconvenus que connaît notre pays
aujourd'hui dans cette partie du monde
merci merci
merci monsieur le député benchek encore
une fois je ne pense pas que
ce que l'on appelle par facilité le
sentiment anti français qui est plutôt
un discours anti-français relayé
puissamment par qui l'on sait soit dans
les motivations des bouts de lorsqu'ils
procède un coup d'état j'espère que nous
en conviendrons
si
[Musique]
vous imaginez qu'il y a eu des
mentalement du dispositif diplomatique
français en Afrique je crois que vous
devrez saluer le fait que nous avons
dès cette année et pour les quatre
années qui viennent réarmer l'appareil
diplomatique français je ne veux pas
pour autant faire de un lien de cause à
effet entre notre présence diplomatique
et l'apparition de coup d'état ce serait
nous prêter des choses qui ne sont pas
de notre ressort convenons là aussi au
sel nous nous intervenons massivement
avec
[Musique]
des volumes d'aide en hausse avec une
concentration qui n'est plus
géographique parce que c'était un
mauvais dispositif mais qui depuis le
dernier conseil présidentiel de
développement
recette par Objectif plutôt que par
géographie pour aider aux objectifs qui
sont les nôtres
enfin vous dites qu'il y a uniquement du
prêt et pas de don et ça n'est pas exact
avant 2017 oui il y avait presque pas
dedans et bien c'est fini depuis 2017 et
depuis 2017 nous avons de plus augmenter
l'aide publique au développement de la
France de
50%. et donc il y a un milliard de dons
de projets AFD aujourd'hui et un Millien
en dons je dis bien et un milliard en
don également du magnétère j'aimerais
que d'autres pays fassent autant que le
nôtre
et une part des dons qui avait beaucoup
diminué et qui augmente et qui est
sensible puisque tout ceci concerne
assez largement si ce n'est très
largement les pays dont nous parlons
aujourd'hui merci merci madame la
ministre vous l'avez vu la question de
l'aide publique au développement
Internet tous les collègues de cette
commission et même et même d'autres
commissions et je pense qu'il serait
important de de d'en rediscuter
d'approfondir la question c'est un c'est
une question qui qui est très sensible
et qui et que les que les parlementaires
ont vraiment à coeur de porter comme
vous l'avez vu avec la loi du 4 août
2021 que nous suivons avec intérêt nous
devrions nous arrêter là mais j'aimerais
que notre collègue le vice-président le
coq qui vous souhaitait poser une
dernière question puisse s'exprimer
parce que dans cette commission nous
avons tous le droit de nous exprimer et
de faire des véritables débats donc
vraiment très brièvement je vous en prie
mon cher collègue vous avez le dernier
mot c'est la dernière question qui aura
le dernier mot
c'est pas moi malheureusement
même la ministre j'ai attendu jusqu'à la
j'ai attendu jusqu'à la fin en fait
parce que je voudrais que vous me
confirmiez que ce que j'ai vu dans la
presse qui était de dire que l'Algérie
allait servir de médiateur est une
fausse nouvelle parce que c'est dans la
presse française que j'ai vu ça c'est
pour vérifier si c'est pas sur les
réseaux et vous en avez pas parlé du
tout donc je me dis que ça doit être une
fausse nouvelle et la deuxième chose par
rapport au Karaba dans notre commission
depuis 2017 moi je suis député depuis
2017 et j'entends parler de cette
situation à l'époque par François
Rochebloine qui qui répétait
régulièrement ce sujet là dans la
Commission et au Conseil de l'Europe
puisqu'on était monté du Conseil de
l'Europe et j'ai l'impression que les
appels de cette population là depuis
toutes ces années pas depuis deux trois
ans depuis 20 ans n'ont jamais été
entendu par par la France c'est mon
impression je sais pas une accusation
merci cher collègue madame la ministre
pour le mot de la fin
sur sur ces questions merci
temporairement pour le mot de la famille
monsieur le petit échanges volontiers ma
situation et la mienne je n'ai pas parlé
de l'Algérie tout simplement parce que
je n'ai pas parlé de beaucoup de sujets
et qu'en particulier je n'ai pas parlé
de la vingtaine un peu plus de la
vingtaine d'entretien bilatéraux que
j'ai pu avoir en marge d'assemblée
générale des Nations unies entre autres
avec mon homologue algérien et au cours
de cet entretien bilatéral nous n'avons
pas parlé que du Niger mais nous avons
évidemment parlé aussi du Niger puisque
l'Algérie avait à proposé ou avait
proposé un plan dont elle imaginait que
les puccistes pourraient l'accepter ce
que nous avons vu c'est que ces puces
disent le rejeter ce qui d'ailleurs
n'est pas de bonne augure sur la
disposition dans laquelle il se trouve
visant à rejeter toute tentative de
médiation comme ils ont rejeté
[Musique]
une fois en tout cas la mission qui
avait envoyé par le président d'indombo
en la personne de son prédécesseur
quelque part et comme il rejette
lorsqu'il y a des conversations les
conversations de fond avec jusqu'ici
chacun de ceux qui les ont approché
merci merci Madame la Ministre donc
Affaires à suivre et notre commission
sera évidemment très attentive à
l'évolution de la situation moi je tiens
à vous remercier au nom de la commission
au nom du Président qui est encore une
fois regrette de ne pas pouvoir vous
accueillir personnellement et de tous
les collègues pour votre présence et de
vous être prêté à cet exercice qui n'est
pas toujours facile mais de l'avoir fait
avec brio malgré tous ces voyages dont
vous nous avez parlé donc merci
infiniment nous vous attendons très
prochainement à la Commission et
d'ailleurs la semaine prochaine et je
vous souhaite à tous une excellente
journée la séance est levée